bah
alors attends feed the world cup on va
récupérer l'échiquier
up et ben voilà
il a l'air fab wen et pau qui arrive
très bien à
ça ils se sont mit a commencé
normalement à 13h30 ouais au début il
avait commencé en avance les parties
suis pas trop compris pourquoi
mais là ils ont commencé à voir on va
voir si tout verture fab
ben oui
bon je pense des quatre
veut dire qu'il ya de moins en moins de
gens pour les pour les rênes au début
des parties est de moins en moins de
gens qui s'intéressent au matchs fur et
à mesure que ça augmente celle inverse
c'est l'arrière du reste en fait al
choubaki
monte
tepa qui coûtait pas qui non mais sur
obs
ateba qui s'est bien oui ce
parfait je vais très heureux non
c'est bien d'être baky
regarder mais qui s'est rarement en
dessous est là au dessus
envoyez la game 1 je pense à être mieux
que les autres fois ou pas moi j'espère
une turbo d'euros personne alors oui
toujours toujours j'espère voir deux
heures deux heures on va au marché de
noël tout ça enfin dit très heureux
j'espère
j'espère bodereau personnes
hop y avait le premier coup évidemment
il va se planter comme d'hab mais tu
veux c'est pas un gars qui envoyait un
coup
joué un coup on voit il a joué
à me pendre un problème de pendule
en scène n'est pas ravi on ne sait pas
indiquent comme on
sera là du ce avaient raison
ce qui laisse animaux ce qui est parfait
pour devenir a pas de nos habitudes
alors c'est quoi ces dessins que c'est
aussi se prendre un peu d 5 ça peut être
un système de londres
si ce qu'est ce qui peut avoir d'autres
on a fait des 5 ouais mais london ce
peut être pas mal pour magnus avec leurs
élèves trois cavaliers f6 est introduit
on verra ce qu'ils n'ont g3 je vais
travailler ici ni là c'est pas des simca
abattu peu bas fonction de feu si ça non
mais j'ai réussi
mes cinq grecque s'ajoute d'ailleurs
mais ok bon
après tu peux aussi sortir trouve
curieusement j'imagine au
f5 ces problèmes en un coup quoi
c'est un art de vous qui est censée
mater imminent pour les blancs oui bon
tu peux aussi faire g6 avec une heure
surtout pas un jour d'une chaîne
j'ai deux sets 6 4 6 6 3
on est peu infléchies s'attendait pas
forcément à se tordre le cou
ça peut être malin en magnus ouais c'est
pas contents ils sont des petites vidéos
je vous réponds
oui
si ce fleuve 5 g 6
p 5
je conçois qu'il va faire
normalement non mais ça a un coût
mais plus
6 ou g2 aimé saint clar je sais pas
exactement pourquoi peut-être ce qui
peut toucher aux pions est touchée b5 je
sais pas ça change quelque chose dans
certaines variantes
à tout moment il ya une petite part
directe
l'apu basse h pour ash
ouais la noria vraiment beaucoup mais
fou et 5 c'est le plus logique en soi
puisque normalement tu fais décès
quattro justement pour sur ces six
cavaliers ces trois mêmes moyens qui
sont mis à jouer g3 sur l'islam y en a
beaucoup qu'il ya le faire je comprends
pas où ils veulent en venir mais je
prends quand même le fond mais jusqu'où
ce qu'ils valent en fait dans la vie
mais on me voir l'institution pourquoi
pas en fait
il va le jouer un coup quoi
on va dire depot a vu son répertoire de
match aussi ça semble logique
ya peut-être une idée quelque part
ajustements après au 6 mai g600 logique
aussi dans le sens où ce matin georges
grün fun et tu peux faire taire une
femme est ce que j'ai trois talents
qu'il faisait peur
donc j'ai ici
logique et aussi ce normalement c'est ce
qui va jouer après ça peut
faire autre chose quoi je refais 5 ou
quoi mais s'est un peu loupé
son café aussi un nom mais peut-être
qu'en fait il veut retarder ces quatre
et introduit un qui a et b d2 ou un b
3-2 à la con tu pour plus que les ventes
avec des français qui faisait avant et
le faire jouer un genre de pollution qui
joue pas trop qui en fait t'es pas
vraiment
alors voile et ses cinq demandés en
tchador c5 c'est jouable mais c'est plus
pour jouer la latte arraché normalement
c'est quand même pas à l'imperator donné
pourquoi
donc ces cinq je crois pas
mais je pense que l'epo il a ils ont pu
ne pas se préparer là dessus parce que
c'est un mauvais coup apparemment
passé sens est réputé être pas terrible
ce g3 mais peut-être justement c'est
très malin pour un joueur qui a peu joué
ces positions là bon si pas mauvais
c'est juste pas lors de coups qu'on a
l'habitude de voir même afin
tout cas il se fait un peu de riz blé
transforma le moins réfléchi
joue pas de thème pour un coût
bon je te disais c'est pour moi le coup
le plus logique pour son répertoire de
ce match
d'affaires fourchette c'est sûr
bon en plus du tout les rendez-vous b4
et il s'en faut n'est pas aussi comme il
joue pas fou b4 c'est pas grave pour les
crocs
voir et dessus j'imagine qu'il va pas
faire ces quatre mâts normalement non
alors il le fait quand même parce que
voilà il a voulu voir tiens si je joue
ce soir de goût que tu fais
mais je pense b3 ou kid
chez parent
et peut ne pas connaître
je pense que ça vaut un métro qui est
juste moi qui a fait péter la descente
et
or je sais pas ce que ça vaut quand j'ai
jamais vu
j'ai senti que c'était ça l'idée
mais pas dans la sauce
bon tels que parti dans la base
mais pas
top joueur
ça a pas l'air fou
mais c'est vrai c'est 5 le coup
j'imagine bon c'est 5 c'est jouable m
façon le fond mais ne sera pas trop
débile
ouais tu verser 5 tu peux partir sur du
c6 v6 machin mais saisissons elles ont
versé 4 et ça va jouer une vente n'était
pas censé jouer
tapez simcoe ici
je pencherais 4 quand même
on lui doit les cinq qu'ils auront pêché
c4
et c5 je crois
il a l'air d'avoir
bon c'est très logique ces cinq bons b2
je pense il doit avoir une idée quelque
part là sinon c'est très insipide on va
aux pierres c'est qui va faire un
échange d'aidés et ses c4 un jour j'ai
une position ouverte avec les fous sur
la grande beune
amcare la non
écoute j'ai déjà joué ça puisse côté
noir
[Musique]
alors tu fais double fond du trou tu
peux jouer en fait cesser pour jouer
c'est pas moi qui déteste jouer donc le
double flingue et hausse est la seule
structure qui m'inquiète pas
partie
non mais dc il va pas faire baisser
faire de ces deux affaires
même cas et des deux peut-être ou
cavaliers à trois un truc qui te
sacrifies option
alors c4 parent nouveauté mais presque
un g2 partir à la base mais qui ont pas
de vélo
ouais bon visuellement ça fait pas peur
même et a raison ça va jouer des si tu
penses il va voir dame c2c pas sylvain
mc2 si vous êtes d'accord que ça fait
ça va pas prête à ces quatre faible mais
tab et cette fève en échange mais bon ça
s'équivaut qu'on va dire mais ça c'est
pas trop inquiétant en soi même ses deux
ont dû prendre je peux pas faire le
set-up dames cette dame français karaté
est d'accord si je vais fouler satie et
17 fois dans la presse a dépensé blanc
peut venir embêter sur ses six à faire
des trucs ans
mais peut-être parce que je veux dire
c'est que oui c'est soit il veut faire
douter de soi décès il veut faire
inscrire deux pions en genre
et c3 je pense là ça
donne des salaires mais les cas veillez
à 3 tiens tu fais ça
quatre des ses cahiers à 3
g pas mais je le vois dans un délire
comme ça ça
votre nom dans lequel
mais bon après tout il ya juste faire
baisser mais visuellement
ça alors quand même
après ça et qui peut jouer se fixe n'est
pas je vous passe souvent ses positions
et pas du tout leur niveau et tout mais
c'est ce qu'un le genre de truc avec les
noirs moi qui fait je déteste jouer
contre les catalanes alors le truc que
je déteste le plus est celle là ne fait
pas du tout peur ce qui est inquiétant
il
décès d'un agent logic dames cette année
kebede
2e choix
faut voir jackass d51 gens
non mais je suis pas effrayé acquéreur
du tout j'essaie de comprendre où il
veut y aller parce que j'ai plus ou
moins concluantes de coder vu que ne pas
laisser dépenser 4 sur ces quatre
facilement
parce que dépenser 400 couples logique
pourrait peut-être qu'il a d'autres
choix mais
ça aurait été mon coup réflexe en tant
que joueur de slave depuis longtemps
décès je serai changé d'âme chez nous et
dames ces deux journées d'amener cette
dame ça qu'est
bon après il joue bonnes armes aux siens
de faire d'une pulsion insipide final un
sexagénaire s'est peut-être qu'il faut
juste les pots mais
on prendrait pas lors du décès de papa
moi j'ai peur de dames français 5 non
mais dans l'autre cas de figure avec des
mots ce qui est mais dès demain
tu peux prendre mais bon
ça ouais ce qu'elle est vert à 5 l'autre
il va venir c'est bon tu peux t'en
foutais là
j'ai de faire à 4 offert x 3 pour faire
1 5 pour faire des trucs
été mal développés voilà il ya un peu de
lait truc c'est peut-être joie pour les
noirs un ami
ouais
à voir pour le moment c'est la prépa
versa
a priori ne l'ont pas dans leur prépare
bien vous serez
vraiment naïf
et
bon c'est pas effrayant on s'attend à
des français après bon il peut se jouer
ici si je sais pas quoi
avoir
une petite idée pour jouer mais ça veut
aussi dire qu'ils n'ont pas l'idée
faisant souvent
quand tu as vraiment des idées dans les
ouvertures comme ça ça n'a pas l'air
effrayant mais non mais pourquoi pas
enfin on va 10 essaye de mettre n'est
pas une position inconfortable c'est pas
forcément la valeur
objective s'il avait pu quelque part
trouver quelque chose qui donne l
avantage de la glisse il aurait tenté
et réussi un aveu de faiblesse dans
l'ouverture le truc c'est que le grand
vide à mon refus de paella petrov conclu
quoi qu'il en soit
mais tu as raison mais c'est donc pas
plus mal d'avoir ça que
tu répètes raso l'autre jour quand
on sait juste pour rire certes dans les
ouvertures ils ont vraiment fait une
croix sur l' avantage
tout ce que je voulais dire par-là
donc j'ai une position un peu comment
rapide ouais utama notre humour
est ce que je trouve ça dommage
à vrai dire
il a pris
sa retraite si on joue en
en langue c'est justement pour avoir des
grandes ouvertures
mais dans tous les cas on a fait c'est
quoi un problème c'est qui fait le grand
débat sa tombe et un nul on n'est pas
appris peut-être qu'ils ont déjà vu
l'opposition pas que la fille des masses
pour prendre cette décision
et donc est ce que c'est vrai c'est de
hockey
dams est là parce que la dame elle est
mal placé sur cette colonne colonne
s'est tu seras pas bien tu sera ouvert
en baisse 6 tu peux 30 du carré d as 4
et en a 5 tu vas prendre du fou des deux
lacs assez clairement recettes après ils
ont un du coup elle sait juste que tu
dis je jouais l'ordinateur va jouer
quelques coups contre comprenez pourquoi
voix et tu as en maillot de bain mais
les planques du coup ces deux traits de
triturer un petit peu
ça mérite de surprendre des poèmes
essais f1 c'est vraiment là le là c'est
vraiment la logique ouverture type
rapide en fait
je se débrouillait tu vas jouer tout
seul j'aurais cependant le stockfisch
aujourd'hui
toi tu vas jouer un petit peu qu'on se
fiche pas moi qui va jouer quelques
coups contre stoke fille
mais ouais et puis tu vas te faire chier
aussi que ces positions elles sont
chiants table
h 30 pas dans le dans pas dans le sens
pun papa difficile c'est dans le sens
ouest est pas amusant à jouer ni pour
les blancs ni pour les noirs d'air tu
vas pas te muter à m avec le blond tu
t'amuses au fond que tu fous tu fais du
loukoum ouais
c'est juste une guerre psychologique
nous aussi on va se faire chez nous
aussi il va tout le monde la voit là
c'est magnifique
tient un stand de saucisses en parallèle
car ça serait bon qu'ils fassent des
merguez stante merguez mariage chicha et
son
saumon mariné tout ce à quoi
il sert à karlsson
normal de repos qu on me dit tiens moi
je connais toi tu connais pas je me
balade très confiant
j'étais venu là pour m'ennuyer je ne
suis pas déçu ah bon
ça tient encore sa promesse chez chaque
vous saumon la seriat pas de chichi
chaque maillon de barbecue devrait faire
si on se déchire tous ensemble cet après
midi je pense qu'on est en train de
faire
non mais c'est vrai que c'est pas très
amusant quoi bomber ou trois voire
pourquoi pas
à me cette web on dépouille doit être
comme vous faites c'est cool and épaules
des abus tempo bien évidemment mais il
doit être un petit peu comme nous ils
essayent de comprendre où veut en venir
magnus et il y arrive pas trop
alors qu'ils aient b d2 moi je parle
chantier vide
à m on va remettre magnus
alimente la femme-chat ravitaillement
est parti faire le ravito je peux voir
des
trucs croquant genre dépistage fait des
trucs comme ça non
tels des dépistages trois avis
s'applique chez moi qui venais un petit
peu plus rien tu as un petit peu le
piquant qui
ça doit être un simple sac crainte de
l'eau pour besoin pour bien avalé
voir c'est un signe de nervosité s'il a
vu que très peu d'attention dumas est
vrai c'est un truc qui reste un peu
collant aux bouches
des bretons voilà c'était du cantal du
saumon de mauvaise qualité l'élevage
c'est c'est ça c'est un truc très bien
pour les gens qui pour le poisson tu
vois tu savais ouais c'est un vrai
conseil culinaire ok ça marche surtout
pour les deux parades et les loups mais
je pense que ça marche aussi pour le
saumon doral pour savoir s'ils ont le
droit devant elle ou et d'élevage un
truc très simple à faire c'est qu'on tue
le match dans tes mots l'air si sale ici
un peu le thunder ouais c'est de la
merde ça doit pas coller en fait
les médias et a remarqué que souvent de
nos jours le poisson colle un peu entre
les dents c'est pas impossible tonnes de
pleine mer c'est pas un poisson pleine
mer normalement et à un vrai loup une
vraie bonne doral normalement ne colle
pas entre les temps parce que je ne peux
plus faire les murs et femmes pourquoi
mais oui mais c
j'ai remarqué le croustibat ne collait
pas entre les donc très bonne qualité
quoi
et j'ai parfois je soupçonne c'est la
même chose avec le saumon ce que le
second derrière je colle un peu entre
les dents ce petit bruit quand tu
relèves temps en
collant la non mais tu remarques de
l'amour tu me travaille non mais je le
vois ça tu veux dire en fait j'ai pas
cherché à rallier vous que lincoln il
colle pas et colle pas mais maintenant
mon arrière grand père était pêcheur
c'est juste pour enfin c'est juste pour
poser les bases
donc le poisson mais j'étais ascendant
sur ma grand mère elle connaît bien son
père était pêcheur
non ça qu'on entre très très grave très
très grave tony dobbins kaulitz
et je pense qu'ils manger des cacahuètes
ce
n'est pas des dates en tout cas non
oms à croquer ou alors qu'il bouffe est
le noyau des dates il essaie
mais il n'aurait pas voulu avaler comme
ça
en tout cas les danses après parmi qui
sait si ça paraît quand même la base du
coup c'était bien on d2 avec le cheval
c'est pour manger non moteurs n'ont
hélas nous on avait aussi qu alors la
turbine est dû aussi peut-être bessines
kobeissy mme
cochart d'offres au crâne je n'aurais
pas fait j'aurais fait sinko
pas ou même nom maintenant pas mal
ouais souci d'atténuer la casse des cinq
tués toro centre
je voulais des coûts qui me paraissent
intéressants
soit tu peux jouer
12 h katia partir non enfin à droite
d'abord même
nom
1.5 direct marche le sien
mais ouais donc ça doit être ça l'idée
oui non mais c'est que je suis à 25 on
s'est arrêté là gmt de la caisse dès
samedi mais on est coupé est simple
pourquoi pas invoquer 5 faut que tu aies
précisément là je sais pas c'est
[Musique]
pas faut savoir ce qu'on fait avec un
art
mais du rajout en pratique mais
peut-être que ça égalise genre vraiment
en force
cependant pas qu'il y ait de ce que dit
qu'en fait c'est une tête là que tu
réussis à faire tourner autour des 8 es
bon sens avastin
donc et ses sites pour ya plein de court
peut-être eu 500 km2
qui s'approche normale et prend 7,4 pour
moi c'est normal
pression jusqu'à la voirie ce qui donne
b5 oui pour l'instant je laisse
réfléchir il donne bessin qui donne un
sens qui
alors mais juste fou 17 je vois qu'ils
le donnent en troisième mais moi j'étais
un peu surpris mon humeur de la tête
caillaud cinq mois en fait si je fais
tout 17 je l'entendrai la tour et je
vous le font huit c'est bon j'ai aucun
problème
[Musique]
mais en fait il est content enfin
toujours kallio 5 qui semble idée quand
même tu bouffes dauphin du beauf et
peut-être foulée 5
jara 4 je pense que s'il vous plaît
torse nu derrière mon passage
en caisse et peut-être plus simple en
fait je ne touche pas des pions c'est
pas db5 fait pas 2 5 0 faiblesse d'une
part et tu sors tout fou 17 du coup
j'aurais eu envie de faire de base je
suis juste retenu de le proposer mr big
n 5 maintenant que moi que vous avez 5
ça va et qu'on leur dit me le confirme
je
choisis à sa a coté noir en fait alors
faudrait pas faire caillou cinq souffre
ou 17 mais qu'est ce qu'on fait je vais
faire juste aux rêves des huit thorax et
8.8 je place tout bien
gros problème
mais bon ok au moins pourquoi pas tu
poses une question à ton adversaire faut
qu'il trouve son set up
de vie même
[Musique]
donc on
j'en conviens c'était juste des petites
ventes qu'on regardait
une époque y revient
broyles échelonnés pour il fait sa
petite tête donnait peu tranquille quoi
complexe
alors pourquoi
reuters epa a réfuté direct mais ils ont
souvent peu dans la merde avec les
normes cavaliers prat avec le fou on
fera bouger avant d'essayer b6000 ya
quatre on pensait sa menace à 5 et
surtout faut être donc double problème
mais regarde l'activité des blancs même
si tu vois l'enfilade jeudi était mal
développé kf3 qui va arriver en le 5 le
fond à 3 les tours souris colonnes a5 a6
peut être des fois il faut bouger d'eau
qui va taper ses jardins benko est quoi
comme une compensation et là tu peux tu
te faudra un vainqueur quand même c'est
pas dur à jouer
oui c'est vrai je suis pas impressionné
un
bon fab boss
spéciaux
non mais parce que je veux dire
je veux dire si
[Musique]
simon la préparation pour juste faire un
nom mais peut-être qu'il va gagner la
partie de ce que les bovins vague a fait
mais en fait tu peux pas avoir une belle
partie partant de là j'ai l'impression
après j'espère me tromper 1 j'espère me
tromper réellement mais geslin et je
vois pas dans quel monde on a une partie
intéressante sega en fait le truc c'est
qu'il te dis oui mais tu joues pas rien
tu joues pas bien ses positions là je
peux le comprendre c'est à dire qu'en
fait là ça joue que sur le fait que ce
n'est pas soit mauvais là dedans déjà on
va pas voir une nouvelle idée on va
ces nouveaux du coup
c'est pas nouveau puisque c'est une
concession après c'est pas une critique
de choix mais pas du tout genre mais ces
genres et chicken m'en parle en bombe
enfin tu vois ça
je sais que tu es d'accord avec moi en
plus ça devient non mais enfin on en est
au point en fait tout ça plein de jeux
dépendantes
finalement faire ça
où est la recherche de la vérité ultime
du match du championnat du monde où
enfin bassila d'ultimes c'est que l'on
fait nul entre 640 coup chacun la quoi
ça sert qu'est ce qu'on fait à la radio
ce genre à quoi ça sert en fait ce que
moi ce qui ce qui fait kiffer c'est de
voir des belles parties des nouvelles
idées des trucs incroyables là on est on
en est au point de voir des sétois juste
pour expliquer aux gens par un truc et
leur parle ça c'est l'équivalent d'un
système de londres en fait oui tu fais
un london juste pour jouer une partie
c'est pareil en fait voir ça en finale
de championnat du monde oui mais tu n'es
pas très bien les catalanes je vais
jouer cette position mais la donne pour
le coup c'était sûr analysé donc ça va
marcher mais oui mais tu en voiture et
on est encore plus bas en fait dans les
cités pour les gens avoir accusé un truc
qui parle et du corps et ses bras des
championnats du monde où tu ne joues pas
très bien cette ouverture je te la joues
on va voir si tu défends bon regarde
cisr a en fait il a défendu
ben c'est tout oui mais je n'y a plus le
lapin ce
ce truc qui fait qu'on regarde les
échecs en fait passer les ordis quoi
on est là pour la beauté de la victoire
pas de la beauté dans la défaite c'est
exactement ça car accepter la pouvoir
une idée incroyable et machins et ouah
c'est dur a réfuté à la clé il a apporté
quelque chose de nouveau enfin ça me
fait penser aux trucs avait donc avait
fait mal à ma santé
va bouger si le premier prix différents
au fait ça me fait penser à ce qu'avait
fait ben là j'aurais 4,5 tirée des f3
des six des g et j'en prends qui prend
quatre élèves 6 kgs ses trois as is fuoh
trois cavaliers g4 ou g5 un g6 fou c'est
un carré des artistes pour ça arrive
dans cette position les noirs ont gagné
le courage 6 met du coup dans une
variante quand les caravanes y arrivant
f5 apa jesse se passer cfoot et 3 je
croyais que 2 kg 3 et 5 quand tu vois ça
tu regardes la partie et essayer de
comprendre tu dis oui incroyable il a
donné h si c'est un coût qui paraît
utile mais où enfin ça c'est beau ouais
ça c'est beau ça c'est un exemple y en a
des milliers c'est juste celui qui me
venait sous ses pas le seul qui me
venait à l'esprit aller mais c'était le
plus simple à expliquer ce que ça paraît
complètement illogique de donner un
cours gratuit à l'adversaire surtout un
coût qui est normalement utile neuf fois
sur dix donc ça c'est beau et c'est pour
ça qu'on garde ses matches face à une
partie dure longtemps et honnêtement
savoir si les pauses c'est assez bien
joué la catalane pour défendre ça ou pas
ouais mais bon en gros la petrov tu peux
rien y faire et
le grand vide âme tu fais revue nature
donc il voit donc on peut parler des
cannes des 5 c 4 6 4 3
6 et 3 ces cinq
six ans le voit souvent ouais mais en
fait ils font leur petite fille née à la
presse et des cahiers prend des cinq ils
font
la
bombe à ces tests non non non c'est pas
assez ces décès des enfants
ouais c'est ça 6 est décédée dame prend
et ils prennent du plomb et quatre non
ouais c'est ça et test final là en fait
je crois que tu peux faire débarquer ici
way to b 5e je sais pas d'ailleurs même
des vies 3 18
kg 5 et 6 ça te merde là bon mais en
fait tu ton là dedans fort toi tu
essaies de jeu principal mais tu as a
way et tu sais que l'autre connaissent
beaucoup 40 tu peux pas faire
as tu peux essayer une fois de temps en
temps
en fait ils ont faire ce que magnus fait
là un changement d'être coup dur aux
trois femmes petite variante est-ce
qu'il ya moins de jeu que là
c'est ça je veux ni rentable
mais oui je souhaite enfin
comment se dit enfin c'est juste que
c'est vrai a changé quoi ces ordis ces
machins
et on me dit que les ordis ont pour ont
permis justement de jouer des peu des
positions intéressantes mais
voilà ça fait deux trois matches
championnat du monde c'est dur quoi
ouais
non des ordis
fait jadis on l'est sont emparés ni
faire de sa vie mais on peut avoir une
certaine nostalgie
commentaire de nantes sur le site de la
ville coup cette friction très riche et
très intéressante
mais
qui va se passer des choses mais je ne
sais pas des nouvelles idées ou pas
assez joué une énième position
s'est jouée une énième position un petit
peu différente pour pouvoir avoir plus
de coups de redick l'autre c'est ça en
fait le truc qui
va voir un bon j'aime bien l'idée qu'on
avait accueilli 6,6 ou des fatwas
ouest il cédé aux 5,6 fait db5 on va
voir ça ça a l'air vraiment fort et
ça l'a vraiment fort
l'ordi en fait mais je veux dire en
pratique je trouve ça
après che mat sais pas j'espère qu'ils
les cinq du coût
qu'est ce qui s'passe ion
2 jeudi doivent vide
est ok ça peut-être que nous faire un
truc tu auras d1 dames bien d'amin
diritti à l'époque il est 5 peuvent
partir non mais sûr qu'il va avoir une
idée qui va faire quelque chose et l'a
fait cai c6 mais je repars actu sent
vraiment que et pour qu'il soit allé là
dedans mais c'est qu'avant ce serait
vraiment mort partout quoi et ça c'est
que pour une partie tu valoir dans cette
partie là demain c'est un truc qui a
réfuté en fait c'est sûr que tu peux tu
peux a égalisé en force
pendant 22 jours et que c'est à chaque
fois je regarde ce que disaient les
autres commentateurs après les parties
et à chaque fois la partie la partie
avec le quadrillage 4g qualité que ça va
être très intéressant c'est turbo de
retraite on dit toujours ça va être
super intéressant puis à chaque fois
bon sur celui qu'il en soit c'est très
impatiente d'être un jour ça va marcher
oui oui il en fait là sur toutes les
ruelles c'était vraiment à chier et
beaucoup d'idées bon
tu parles avec la d'après il regarde il
n'y pas trop de pain
mais là j'espère et je sais pas
aujourd'hui j'avais espoir de grosses
catalan avec un gros truc en fait
j'étais très chaud aujourd'hui mais
écoute quand même je ne pas retenir
la fin de championnat est très serré à
chaque jour où j'allais sur les longues
c'est relou bas on dit ce qu'on pense en
battant à chaque jour on espère voir une
grosse partie avec ça on est tout le
temps chaud en fait on espère toujours
voir un beau truc et où on a espoir en
fait mais c'est comme si tu regarde un
match de foot en fait est que tu as
espoirs avant et puis que
j'étais un peu déçu quoi c c'est comme
ça on espère mais
c'est comme ça
on espère voir des belles idées des
beaux trucs
à voir on va espérer que
avoir de belles idées alors j'imagine
qu'il prend ce quatre ans il perd
logique madrid pour l'instant en fait on
a deviné les cook et l'espace et le b3
assez tôt le dmc 2 qui a laissé le pion
aussi et le setup donné peut donc vous
dire celui d'un chat pour l'instant où
vont les coups ils vont avoir lieu
d'accord vous montrer les bars étaient
coup il ya des petits pièges et uri
messer petit pialat c'est sans tabac et
ses y sont cool parce que tu peux te les
prendre mais en fait c'est pas
mais pour le coup c'est
sûr que les français cap sur une
question portée pour
lyon vraiment là selon ce qui va jouer
c'est pas pareil fodé ça je vous dise le
choix pratique qui me semble pas trop
dur à gérer mais
pratique est objectivement probable on
est sûr qu'il pensait que le meilleur
coup c e 5 ou b 5 trucs turbine 10 au
début mais ça
ça fait des trous des options il faut
être bien sûr
[Musique]
on va voir il joue il joue vraiment
joue vraiment l'homme on va voir ça peut
payer 1
ça peut payer
écoute mais bon qui est français 4
j'imagine un dame branche restent très
surprise puisque qu'un chat marquer des
deux
[Musique]
un
je ne sais pas quoi hirschi magnus parce
que ça et d'avoir dans les fichiers
essayé de sonner à la guerre je crois
que tu ailles ferme les yeux regardent
même pas les chics et non
voilà qu'à
des spectateurs les langues c'est pas
les plus populaires un an contenir
autant à prendre du plaisir
je sais pas on te dit ce qu'on pense de
la position et la partie on peut pas
faire plus en fait
on peut pas faire plus que te dire notre
ressenti est ce qu'on pense après
c'est quand c'est comme ça afin schéma
comment dire en fait femme de ben un
match de tennis tu as des double-fautes
des trucs comme ça en fait espère voir
des beaux points puis tu espères que ça
arrive quand ça arrivera on sera très
heureux pour le moment on dire on attend
qui est un as et un chose
d'extraordinaire en fait
on espère l'extraordinaire en fait à
chaque partie parce que c'est les
meilleurs joueurs du monde fins c'est
sensé en tout cas ma niche c'est sûr que
c'est le meilleur n'est pas censé être
le 2e après c'est pas le cas au vélo
mais quand même il a gagné les candidats
et championnat de russie essaie numéro
deux mondial et espère l'exceptionnel à
chaque fois en fait
non mais là
pas mécontent du choix d'un guide
ouverture n'est pas mécontent non
j'espère que tu as raison femmes
il faudrait qu'ils aient encore deux
trois coups
il faudrait qu'il fasse encore deux
trois ou deux trois coups d'ordi et
peut-être qu'il pourra skier en fait
n'est pas dû manquer le c4 il aurait eu
le c4 mais ça c'est de sa faute parce
que c'est trop bas
on est sur une partie à trois résultats
plutôt 2 quand même un ennemi way dont
un ennemi au
nul tenue ok c'est toujours résultats
plus probable y en a eu on a dix sept
nuls consécutifs aux matchs championnat
du monde donc c'est plus probable mais
ok il ya un peu de cas un blanc dans le
règne oui oui non mais ils ont un truc
sans risque il peut presser mais sûre
qu'elle prend ses quatre ça va dépendre
des actions menées pour le 5 c'est ce
que nous disent les ordis
enfin moi j'aurais peur de jeu va
peut-être faire
ce que comme on vous montrait en fait
donc il prend ses gardes on imagine
qu'il va faire
être pourquoi aux 5 c'est tellement
tentant parce que le problème des noirs
dans tous les grands bides à mêlée
catalane d'autant plus et ce fou qui a
du mal à sortir qui est bloquée
perception donc première chose deuxième
chose les docks et valérie recettes
quasi s'installerait bien dessus ça fait
plaisir si les blancs ils font ça par
exemple il ya un échange ça vous le fou
j'ai deux on avocat veille au centre
c'est jusqu'où l' oncle 5 ça réglait de
problème il n'y a pas de calais qui
vient mais on défend bien et lui qui
était moche bon bah il va faire coucou
quelque part quoi le truc c'est que mon
penser que peut-être les blancs on faire
ça ça cloue bon ok très bien
deuxième truc quand on prend et qui adam
prend suis là et reste en prise donc qui
concerne des petites combinaisons dessus
ou même plus que ça il peut traîner mon
premier problème après ça fait bien
passer deux cases le fait d' or le
clouage donc on peut songer à des
manoeuvres comme ça où un retour pour
rebondir et c est donc l or ont des
petits trucs concrets à gérer alors
c'est pas des positions d'une complexité
avec des pièces sont prises partout mais
en fait faut faire gaffe parce que
il peut y avoir des trucs mais aussi
s'équiper comme plan alors voilà cinq
finalement c'est cool mais il ya ça
comme problème b5 même délire on attaque
le cavalier ondimba jamais trop fou là
je vais lutter contre celui là et vous
voyez bien que les pièces en l'air sur
la colonne ça peut être un souci est de
dos on ouvre le fou des primes sur la
tour donc ça demande un dépôt de calcul
et voir s'il a des soucis ou quoi voici
les change tout ça va et finalement
c'est pour ça je vous ai bafodé s'être
le choix pratique je fais rien de ce
pays je vais être ma tour je veux
ensuite plan qu'il fout là bas ils me
l'on mettra plus simple dans les pattes
je mets les tours au mieux un poil moins
bien je sais mais en fait ça va ça
al'air gérable ce qu'ils avaient leur
pénible à première vue mais ça ne va pas
du tout c'est ça je dis ouais bon si je
perds la perdre tous ces cons sauf qu'on
la perd pas
surtout que sur l'a4 ont peu reculé mais
on peut aussi jouer le coup
intermédiaire menace donc ok ça c'est
cool pour les noirs donc si caillou 5
est pas si grave après bâle et blanc
peuvent eux des coûts évidemment on peut
y avoir une position comme ça qui se
passe je sais pas at war quelque part la
dame qui va mettre la pression sur la
diagonale ou peut-être des cayes g5 qui
partent pour échanger lui avec le fouet
et les petites îles et ses joueurs je
veux dire donc sur chaque truc qui peut
se passer des choses mais ce que qu'elle
veut dire c'est qu'à priori quand on va
mettre les grosses turbines dessus ça va
pas passer l'analyse comme étant une
nouvelle manière de jouer avec les
blancs qui peuvent vraiment mettre en
danger les noirs mais la première fois
qu'on est confronté à ça bah déjà les
pauvres alors qu'ils réfléchissent aux
trois options à laquelle lui plaît le
plus ne pas se prendre une balle perdue
là dessus ou quoi est donc inscrit hier
par là c'est que ça vous pas un nouvel
univers tu vois si on prend le match de
championnat du monde précédent avec la
chasse n'est qu'un feu se reprend le
match de championnat du monde de carlson
karwan parce que c'est des gens un peu
de culture ils vont comprendre là je
veux en venir en fait on a ouvert tout
un univers et chaque match de
championnat du monde généralement ouvre
un tout nouvel univers on pourrait citer
pour le match de carrière car il ya
crime peut-être moi mais si tu prends le
match à nantes cramique par exemple sur
le sol us ya beaucoup il ya beaucoup de
matches du monde qui ont ouvert de
nouveaux univers mêlant en fait ça a
ouvert qu'à et b5 b6 et ça carrément
ouvert que là dessus tout le monde sait
qu'à aider 50 ça c'est un truc qu'on
faisait quasiment pas été considéré que
tu aimes tu devrais être mauvais et
c'est devenu mail après le match carlson
caruana donc en fait même si beaucoup de
nuls ce qui était intéressant c'est que
ça ouverte ça a juste ouvert un nouveau
champ du jeu en fait des nouvelles
positions qu'on analyse n'est pas
esthétique intéressant moi je kiffe et
regarder en direct c'est parti là même
si sa finissez par des huîtres cache toi
tu étais surpris tu fais des trucs que
tu avais jamais vu
et ça al'air beaucoup évolué et la
théorie la plus au sud kébé vite il va
les deux d'ailleurs et c'était assez
extraordinaire et ses dépositions
vraiment intéressante
et au noir il y avait je me rappelle la
première partie au noir de la deuxième
tête au noir de karwan à quand il avait
envoyé le pion là dans le candidat mme
imbeault et ses textes en fait dix ans
que tu avais parlé de position
d'ouverture et même si ça faisait nul
c'était des parties mémorables
incroyable en fait c'est que tu
découvres est des nouvelles idées des
choses que ça remettait en question un
peu de pâte forcément ta vision du jeu
mais ta vision d'une ouverture la
manière de jouer une ouverture est-ce
que géré par lasalle a pour le moment
fait ça remet rien en question c'est que
des petites idées pour jouer le head's
up parce que à maintien on veut jouer
sur son point faible mais moi ce que en
fait dans ma vision des échecs classique
je suis assez beau de vigny qu'un sens
fait ils sont intéressants si on cherche
la vérité
si on recherche pas la vérité pour moi
en fait c'est mort parce que c'est
l'essence même des parties longues c'est
la recherche fondamentale de la vérité
du jeu et quand on sort de ça en fait
faites moi c'est par les nuls qui
m'embête c'est ouais c'est de sortir de
la recherche fondamentale en fait non
mais là ils jouent au loto du match on
n'y joue
tantôt trader c'est un peu en danger
sur un terrain glissant pour % d'heures
c'est vrai qu'ils jugent glissant
wendy ne pouvait pas gérer ça
c'est qu'à mon fils aurait dû goût
philosophiquement
ça me fait moins qui fait on va dire ça
comme ça
l'essence même c'est de gagner le titre
c'est tout oui peut-être mais du coup
c'est comment dire c'est pas une
question c'est comme jouer avec manu je
comprends tout à fait ce qui fait ça en
tant que ton petit qu'observateur en
fait on va dire ça comme ça
genre tu chantes le bilboquet je regarde
pas sûr que le but c'est un champion de
bilboquet au jeu
mais la finale de championnat du monde
c'est peut-être pas le bon moment pour
la recherche mais il se trouve que dans
l'histoire du jeu d'échecs le final j'ai
perdu mon don sans arrêt était le point
de révolution en fait non quand tu
connais l'histoire c'est censé être
justement l'endroit
t'améliores le jeu en fait
face améliore la manière de jouer des
êtres humains globalement et du coup je
suis un peu déçu de ne pas le retrouver
en fait mais c'est tout on ce personnel
non magnus suffit pas trop non non je
sais pas pourquoi réfléchit d'ailleurs
je viens
mais peut-être kafia dame cran et
d'envoyer dame vers h4 fait un truc que
j'ai pas spécialement considéré je viens
mais peut-être ça l'intéresse faire dame
36,4 ou b2c dire tiens tu préfères
cahill et de henri iv et changer le cap
6 j'enlève un défenseur d'un droit
j'aime la dame vers 1 h 4 gens simples
dommages 4 gigas g5 et que j'enseigne
aussi bien juste à ça en fait qu'ils
avaient presque sembler logique mais
le fait qu'ils réfléchissent et que
finalement pas si clair qu
il a pris du cavalier malgré tout mais
je pense qu'ils se rappellent en vrai
ce que magnus et stone soup a réuni m
non non je le fais plaisir d'écrire 60
ans d'histoire
donc l'ordi donne soit b5 soit 11,5 b55
si ça marche ça peut vraiment fermé mais
c'est pas évident à jouer
non je trouve que
[Musique]
j'aurais eu du mal à le jouer
je pense pas que vous en arrivez à un
plafond de verre et qu'on sera plus
jamais surpris en fait non j'ai
l'impression que habituellement il
découvre quand même il joue quand même
des trucs de ouf 1,6 à des baux
non-match championnat du monde a pour
moi le dernier match en championnat
c'était grâce surtout à lyon c'est assez
incroyable quand même
mais bon magnus tu ça y est très
pragmatique en fait
je comprends tout à fait vrai que
nous sommes c'est parti contre allende
en fait juste il était plus jeune enfin
il y avait 30 ans de moins je
n'avais entendu attend de moi il faisait
partie longue je sais des prix n'a
fait il n'a pas fait de nouveauté
fracassante comme petrossian qu'on a
fini en fait fond de court est ok ça
suffit a gagné contre car yakine
bas c'est un peu comme la en fait anti
marshall antimarché anti marshall mais
jamais une victoire
contre caruana mais finalement ça vient
pas du fait de magnus tu sais jusqu'à
roanne qui rêve avec plein d'idées un
des rares à être capable d'en face était
hyper intéressant en fait le match était
vraiment intéressant et caruana
assez caruana en fait peut-être
l'instigateur de ce match puisque choses
là ça repart sur un mode de karuïa qui
n'en fait
mais c'est pour ça tu as vu et est à
remarquer dès que j'ai pensé un autre
patch représente un intéressant j'ai
parlé d'un an de cramique minutes un peu
plus longtemps même les coquelicots
cramique au système au lieu de deux mais
à l'époque on pensait que le match était
pas terrible
non mais en plus sans vent d'ouverture
il y avait les crocs avec les corps est
mêlée confuse était venu
jouer des 4èmes
t il jouer ou quatre il perd sur la
petrov par un parti de machos cran
switcher des quatre s'attendait pas il
avait des idées sur des quatre il a fait
le fou prend 1,6 à granby dame
pour faire baisser enfin peut-être jort
adams et 2006 comme la mais qui regarde
en face est fou prend 1,6 s'il voulait
provoquer 6,6 en l'air et on reprend le
dessin que tu reprends
qu'il avait il avait gagné le marché
extraordinaire c'est une des plus belles
parties de l'histoire des matches
championnat du monde y avait hier il est
beau truc
déjà que travnik outre l'aspect
historique et a quand même eu un
tremblement de terre de la berlinoise
qui
[Musique]
en fait c'est que les matchs du
championnat du monde les beaux matches
champion du monde je dirais il marque le
jeu d'échecs leurs casseroles cramique
la berlinoise est encore aujourd'hui
c'est une ouverture et alpha 0 a montré
que c'était mail ouais donc c'est assez
extraordinaire
en fait c'est juste je comprends les
gens de chatte qui disent l'inversé me
suis dit faire une différence de vision
jeu d'échec c'est qu'en fait je regarde
les rapides pour le spectacle et les
longues pour le fondamental
tu vois ce que je veux dire et du coup
comme la longue n'est pas fait
fondamental je la trouve longue pour
rien en fait puisque la ddt finalement
le patois de mon point de vue je suis
pas forcément raison mais de mon point
de vue on attend de savoir si les peaux
va faire une erreur ou pas et du coup on
voit pourquoi lui donner deux heures fin
autant lui donner moins de temps il y
aura plus de chances qu'il fasse une
erreur vous y trouvez qu'il faut 5 j'ai
trouvé que ce soit
l'admirable résoudre des problèmes en
peu de ces sa
maison c'est le mélange des deux qui me
mais bon après ça l'écossaise de
kasparov aussi oui c'est vrai kasparov
et karpov
écossaise crs en avant pas mal oui aussi
et oui voilà il ya beaucoup de matches
championnat du monde qui ont
marqué par de leur empreinte l'évolution
du jeu d'échecs et ma mère de jouer ça
je trouve que c'est extraordinaire
à ce moment là c'est pour le fondamental
autant gardeur nordique en 3d non parce
qu homme plus ordi et plus forts cordy
sol donc les choses qui prépare chez eux
en fait sont plus fines que ce qu'on
aurait fait avec un ordi seul en fait
c'est au-dessus
importance à réussir à comprendre
d'ailleurs il n'est pas qu'ils aient les
matches un peu plus sordide à leon en
espagne
magnifique ça shirov qui jouent en train
en il me semble
bon comme important des points d'un
certain prix
5 / tour 4-6
6-1 il avait joué sur 4 mais s'est passé
chez ba c'était une nouveauté
mais on a fait la partie ces prépas de
flyers pour la peine ça
en fait c'est pas l'écho soyons précis
mais ce n'est qu'au plus oui j'ai
toujours su que ce videur dans la team
d'en face n'allait pas à l'analyse est
assez profondément tu sais qui viennent
intel dell comme
mais oui c'était extraordinaire cette
partie extraordinaire de se dire qu'à
l'époque les ordis pas assez puissant
pour comprendre
semble être la meilleure mine d or des
justes pour tenir son rang viens tu sais
le 5
ou le plus logique de bad réfugiés 5 ça
paraît c'est chiant
en fait juste peut-être tu continues par
2,4
attend votre page qu'autre chose ah ok
mais tu laissais fond et tu vas faire
juger
chute active tu as pris ta paire de
foutus cloisonne le fou g2 et voilà
mais si c'est ça
mais je veux dire mon faux
faut réfléchir quand je dis ça parce que
en fait tu dis non me fait trop de
concessions la ligne en fait ça va
100 ça c'est dur
mais bon qui nous a pas fait c'est katia
deux jours
il peut très bien ne pas faire ça non
plus
messi fait fou 17 jours
ci c'est mon choix mais c'est vraiment
le moins bon de tout ce mois en partie
j'aurais push cette ligne là
pour une raison simple au refus un
mauvais joueur de catane avec les noirs
et c'est pour ça que je n'ai pas peur ma
logique n'a pas l'habitude c'est que
j'aurais pensé que si je mets il faut
enlever cette géniale is en force
pas se plaint non mais
mais sauf la ligne vin se fait en
revanche on ne sait pas sûr j'aurais
joué mais ça a été ma logique un peu à
la con
fait cinq chats mauvais jour du catalan
peut-être ou pas mais gère pas joueur
naturel et peut-être la même logique
mais écoute ça va de travers les cinq
bons tuyaux 5 je suis
tellement sûr oui bon ça c'est sûr
et qui aimait 4 efficace je vais montrer
qu'elle prend 1,5 et prendre 5 / foulée
c'est tabou dans ces 5 qui c'est pour ça
que c'est pas position aurait eu très
envie et tourbe et 800 cavalli c6 très
thématiques pour chat tu les gagnes en
plus tôt faisait 5 1
il y avait quatre obligé il va faire
attaque la dame est donc walesa un coup
de répit pour sortir le fond de satin et
du coup tu à régler le problème du fou
mais moi j'aurais été très content et
pieds-noirs si j'avais réussi j'avais
imaginé que je rentre là dedans et je
vois pas un coup fort la direccte pour
les blancs je me serais dit
stratégiquement je suis tranquille
la dame en b2 j'aurais été très hauts
revenus il n'y a plus de flou b2t non
mais du coup j'ai 5 oui mais bon
bref si ce n'est peut-être faire flasher
4g
5,5 faut regarder quand même
sacrifice peut peut-être donner envie ok
ok respecte un peu dangereux hockey
grospiron tu le saches 4 oui mais c'est
un peu chiant ou en léger quoi
ces 10 kg qui a un très
bon ça doit aller un point
alors g5 je vais juste petites turbines
pour un sound en fait c'est quand même
le coup pour un con regarde ce qui est
proche des 5
non en fait ce constat fait france et de
navarre
est logique on reprend
nom reprend maintenant il a dit non
faire piège cette heure française et
justement broie pranger 2 et il faut
prendre les dames b cet échec tu me dis
que l'on peut montrer
qu'il est fils va bouger ça mais faut
prendre les devants face aux affaires
nul th 7
ouais
j'ai
juste eu prendre plus de risques avec
les blancs
et bd cinq exactement dam des deux
fautes robe magnifique
sans hardy j'arrive sans envie et le
problème c'est que sur des fautes
accueil aux 4 j'avais pas pensé que
c'était faux problème un instant
sur france 3 je pense qu'il ya quatre
ans avec le meilleur foot roi pas dire
c'est ça le coup mais qui m'a fait le
cas je réponde au cahier grosse ligne et
dans ces deux dames détroit
ouais le fou le fou qui est en ville at
sauf le truc france il faut absolument
faire dame prend des cinq du coup sûr
quelque 400 lignes
et tu prends ils préféreront peut-être
ça fait même nul à la fin je sais pas
j'aime ça ça peut être dans la turbine
de magnus
mais là bon on est plutôt moins bien
clément
peut-être tenir mais
meiway du coup ce sacrifice
cela dit non j'ai 5 à 3
d'accord et b4 dame mais deux fois
blessé est rouge et 5h
6h 4g 5 à 3 ok c'est logique
car elle est assise c'est maintenant
qu'ils avaient changé il est plus là
pour revenir tomber t on qu'ils doivent
faire cherche en fait à
b jamais un b to b 4
jours à 10 à
2,2
en fait ouais mais bon
oui mais c'est pas digéré les deux en
fait le roi il est pas si mal actionnera
en fait talent fou de cases noires et
c'était quasiment acquis sont affaiblis
que peut avoir un plongeur fois elle fut
de fou g7 à toulouse - attendez je peux
faire les noirs ici personnellement ça
va passer à 3 est pas si je vais le pion
à troyes le foin f8
à botter bien
donc je ré content d'avoir ça mais après
c'est le truc c'est que soit tu l'as
dans la turbine avec les blancs tu peux
rentrer dedans
soit tu l'as pas et ça peut faire peur
parce que tu peux perdre aussi aux plans
mais n'est pas fou qui trouve tout ça
quand même le g5 de relever
ouais mais ma guise charge de flash 4
aussi parce qu'en fait il à dire quand
tu dis que tu es b 4 dan b2b sexe si tu
fais bouger 5 h 6 en fait t'as plus le
choix parce que fouet le système f 6 e s
est mis au noir l'a déjà on s'est un peu
à ses pairs de fou donc en fait c'est
magnus qui a le premier la
responsabilité de la connerie maintenant
à près de 5 ce qui fait d'eux non mais
je vais reparler cavaliers ou 5 et
bekaert et forcé ouais ben b2fair norman
est normal foulée 7c seul coup
donc en fait cette position tu là et
c'est toi qui a la responsabilité du fou
g5 way au gland ou alors tu fais à trois
ils partent public atteint tu fais un
truc symétrique et hussein est devant
mais
je crois qu'il va faire beau geste
mais il peut la perdre trois résultats
pour le coup ça peut faire une belle
partie parce que
je pense il était pas content de ça
nulle l'autre jour il pourrait s'en
prendre à lui-même ou quoi c'est juste
c'était comme ça mais il n'aime pas
faire des nuls aussi insipide et
jeter les blancs à poubelles ça va il
veut pas faire tous les jours non plus
comme
il peut mais c'est un peu relou
mais après ça peut être un scénario à la
carlsson cariat qui dans ces cas là je
pense la position que bien convenir
finalement fait appel choix qui convient
à son style et qui en plus objectivement
est pas mauvais et là il a évolué pour
ça
je dois dire
en fait là où il a pas de fait pourrait
prendre un con comme moi dans ton équipe
et te dire ce que tu aurais joué
mais pas de potes turbine donc mais la
tuque la turbine nourriture on dit ah
tiens qu'est-ce que tu aucun cas soit tu
es nul
s'arrêter mon réflexe en fait va
s'arrêter le truc que j'aurais essayé de
calculer si ça marchait
je répète pour la énième fois je suis
très mauvais dans les catalanes donc
c'est toujours une cape ann es toi mais
là ça passe c'est pas de chance en fait
parce que je pense que si ces mêmes
s'ils passent mal
si beau tu prends ton temps
[Musique]
il aurait pas trop ils ces quatre non
plus avoir montré conscient
mais en fait ça changera pas mon avis en
fait n'est pas c'est que même si la game
est très belle s'assurera par mon avis
que c'est parce que j'attends d'un match
du championnat du monde mais après
entre le trop de puristes peut-être non
en fait mais
mais après je crois que tu auras moins
grands moins ce que tu cherches mulhouse
en plus en plus de partis ou juste ils
veulent je sais que magnus a amené au
jeu en fait
du coup pour toi ce pas trop intéressé
mais le nombre de partis qu'il a gagné
dans sa jeunesse quand il monte à 28 80
etc et les finales qui vaut 8 heures
c'était pas démarrer prépa en fait je
veux des petites lignes pour faire jouer
oui mais voilà c'est vrai on est à 15
d'affilée quoi ça marche pas trop non
plus non mais bon il perd pas son petit
monde c'est sûr mais quand il a près de
là récemment dans les tournois tu vois
comme vivendi qui fait gagner les ans
mais là il envoya ya 10 mai c'était
nouveau c'était pas son style ms parce
qu'il avait
possible mais voilà mais en fait le cas
en scène quand je l'en tête -
ici on parle de vian 50 en quoi c'est un
gars qui déjà des positions il n'y avait
pas grand chose il est vrai très
longtemps été au top physiquement il te
remarquer tous les petits détails dans
la position est en fait ils pouvaient
être joués 90 coup au meilleur niveau
dans l'est d'en faire autant en face à
mais c'était pas je viens avec des idées
de ouf dont l'ouverture
est d'ailleurs la légende ça disent ah
oui tu vois il connaît mal les
ouvertures est quand même très fort
c'est ce que tout le monde disait
connaissez mal c'est juste s'il voulait
jouer des trucs comme aujourd'hui pas
très bien réputé ou mais pas réfutable
c'était pas de la merde juste vas-y on
va josé chaque coin
n'ont cessé c'est typique son approche à
lui quoi
non il faut espérer que sa part dans le
foulée 5 6 4 et 5 ça peut être
plus de chances de gains que magnus et à
l'épaule à la partie soit très féminin
qui a trouvé le bet5
meneboo faudrait vraiment qu'ils nous
fassent une partie sérieuse et appliquée
et
comme on dit et qui cherche à la moi je
réfléchis race ferman quoi
comme pour
qu'on aime parce que quand il a eu le ce
genre de truc rond de 2 11 et tiens ça
va lui convenir oui bon on va dire il a
sauté sur le to qui perd pas quoi
parce qu'il s'est pris une prépa
allemagne et il a il n'a pas trop
réfléchi il faut rejouer un truc bien
appris oui mais je ne sais pas foutu
juste le bon temps il s'est pas mis en
pl ace il a assez réfléchi pour trouver
déjà arrivé en début de coupe du monde
qu'un candidat joue pour gagner avec les
noirs ah bah oui enfin je vous pourriez
vous rencontrez avec en championnat du
monde
non mais en fait en gros si on me
demande avant la partie ce que nous le
savoir ils vont toujours dire oui mais
mais s'ils ont une occasion faut essayer
infosfoot foulée saisir les occasions
mais je pense c'est une autre époque
celle approche de fisher blanc noir je
m'en fous
maintenant on le voit moins déjà même
contre des mecs pas trop fort bon c'est
ce que alias a très bien fait pour le
coup il veut pour le bien contre tout le
monde mais
des gens le voient moins mais compte
déjà de l'élite tu penses même pu
essayer déclinera en fait la tuer ton
truc et si le mec vraiment trop gagner
ces deux contrées
avant la partie si tu as un truc de
contre oui tu vas essayer en fait mais
fisher à l'époque avant la partie
dépense blanc noir de démolir
donc
mais est-ce que la prépa elle pourrait
être peut-être qui s'en rappellent pas
parce que l'on y réfléchisse vraiment
depuis longtemps mais est ce que sa
prépa ça pourrait vraiment être tout ça
en fait
parce que genre si c'est tout ça c'est
pour une partie c'est bien joué après
s'ils se rappellent pas alors pourquoi
il se rappellerait pas juste pour
expliquer en fait je pouvais pas
vraiment savoir ce que n'est pas allé
jouer ici bas mais bon j'ai quand même
dit que je pense reçu ce
site à penser cela prouve avoir cette
position ouais en fait cette fonction
elle est tellement à fos facile à voir
chez toi là bas en fait je sais pas ici
si on veut jouer mais tu sais que c b 5e
5 fu 17
du coup il va tuer mon dieu on aurait
donné la position que toi tu as eu
l'intuition du airbus le
grand plus je sentais je voulais faire
b34
en fait un centaure quelle femme on te
fait réviser que cette position-là à
fond
sommeil c'est le redis qu'il en fait
nous le centaure te fait réaliser ça à
fond bon c'est pas ce faisant il faut le
faire mais quand on sait que c'est
devenu compliqué enfin on peut on peut
de faire la visée safran si tu révises
cette position là pendant quatre heures
le matin je pense que tu peux rentrer
dedans quand même c'est beaucoup quoi le
fameux chef ce
truc extraordinaire non il ne va pas
jouer v5 soit et trompe toi moi je ferai
de moi que je fasses va faire aussi
c'est vraiment très con comme
c'est beau que le centaure khaffane le
préparateur idéal par la catalane contre
n'est pas l'un comprend les coûts
l'autre est très con et le mélange des
deux alors j'ai deux de la finesse de
l'ain et de la connerie de l'autre c'est
simple comme une sauce sucrée salée très
finement assidus aigre-doux
c'est magnifique non c'est bon
mais non mais c'est bien ça oui là pour
le coup il
le coup même si c'est dans le fichier ce
truc là il l'a plus quoi ou alors ça lui
plaisait pas plus que ça il sait que ce
qui peut faire au pire et là ils
cherchent autre chose
ça arrive des fois que les joueurs
changent devant l'échiquier ils ont le
fichier ils savent
en fait tant en fait de faire ça a
peut-être trop d'infos sur
non mais ça arrive je sais maman en fait
mais si ce rappel puisque gens là de
toute façon tu as déjà miné peau sous
pression autant tu vas pas claquer 25
minutes à laisser récupérer réfléchir
par plaisir pour pour faire le mal
la case 3 est trop moche bah oui et non
tu as fait pas pression là en fait tu
l'as trouvé cette direct tu penses pas
qu'il y avait 4 ans fait toc et en 3d ça
il va nulle part
sata sur kazim cédé 1 kw annoncées par
avis quoi tu te bloque les fous j'ai
fait un grand pas de fait dire oui je
serais fou bd ou quoi mais on pouvait de
garder fou prend 1,3 à te faire doubler
les pions et c'est pas ou fait en fait
tu vois les tapas en fait c'est pas que
la caisse soit match en soi c'est que là
il n'y a pas de suite
la s'harmonisent mal avec avec la casa
cinq
bons emprise mais sinon pourquoi pas que
ces mecs-là cas ce soir c'est pour ça
est ce que la casa 5
à 6 kg un roman si vous pouvez lors des
6es plaisent à dire
binic de narc
[Rires]
binic doner kebab ou
au la pub a
alors donnart qui va avec c'est un
joueur hollande il pas turc
c'est vrai en plus
une faute fini que merck
avait sorti la punchline contre pornic
génial quotidiens ont demandé à damas
car il est vide
c'est trop bizarre
peut pas faire québec a déjà tué bouge
ta dah tu vas sur une case de merde
dame bien tu vas te prendre des foules
mais cette fois en quatre ans de faire
complètement hem en fête à castres fc 6
tu mets les 45 tu do peut en fait là
c'est juste que ces mots branagh ouais
c'est no brainer quoi qui a valu aux 5
c'est sûr qu'il va le jouer en fait il a
qui a valu au 5 et cavalli b4 c'est sûr
mais juste il veut pas jouer tout de
suite parce qu'ils calculent un peu plus
loin ça sert à rien mais mais pour le
coup
ça m'arrive aussi mais en fait c'est con
ça se fait si tu sais que c'est le coup
tu le fais est déjà temps un coup de
moins calculé après
c'est pas dur un coup pour lui en plus
ou en moins mais en fait ouais mais pas
le choix pas le choix bah oui on nettoie
il est pas sûr à 100%
offensif autre chose définition des deux
clubs le lien
avec l'autre cavaliers
ok
bon
charlotte cavaliers c'est juste bizarre
de ne pas bouger une pièce en prison en
fait on va te faire la même chose
simplement la main de la variante jouer
un coup tu as envie ton cavaliers
t'attaquer quoi mais ça tu peux y
réfléchir à vrai dire c'est pas bon ça
marche pas mais en fait on va dire le
réflexe - composé une pièce attaquer bon
c'est sûr la protégée sur la bouger mon
là quand c'est un pion qui attaquent tu
peux pas te protéger en fait tu dois
bouger bon pas tu vas rester à autre
chose mais c'est normal de bouger en
fait
c'est dur en fait parce que chaque bon
pas mal de gens aiment bien plutôt à un
petit niveau quoi mais c'est essayer de
créer une menace équivalente ou
supérieure mais en fait c'est dur de le
faire marcher faut jamais oublier que
quand tu attaques est à bouffer menace
au-dessus tapez apparaît la première
menace était juste fait diversion à
faire autre chose donc en jeu l'autre
aura paraît ton truc la première menace
ou tu te fais bouger tapiès tu vas
encore à avoir besoin de le faire est
juste peut-être tu pourras pas ou que tu
as contre mana ça ne marche pas assez ou
face tu te compliquer les choses quoi
alors soit tu vois très clair et ça peut
être très fort on va dire que la plupart
du temps fou voilà pas s'inventer de
l'aïe fait le truc attaqué bon ok je le
bouge
et surtout que la nouvelle classe dans
le cinq
alors après voilà on a vu la ligne qui
est beckham machin qui est compliqué
mais toute façon a priori il faut le
faire
dernier truc marrant sur les échecs et
j'ai vu qu'il ya eu un sondage du
sportif de l'année en pologne dès 2012
ou devant lewandowski vrai
nom mais je sais je sais je sais je sais
me
faisait chier bah moi je trouve c'est
plutôt bien non non c'est bien mais
j'étais content franchement j'étais
content c'est la bonne nouvelle du jour
tu vois mais j'ai vu passer le truc il
l'a mis sur son twitter dont c'est que
tu un bravo bon ben jawad mais c'est
vous qui allez on aussi rate le ballon
d'or mais il rate aussi le sportif le
année en pologne ouais mais en vrai je
trouve que c'est juste un choc s'est
justifié je suis fatiguée la coupe du
monde d'échecs pas assez gros dingoo du
monde c'est un sport quand même majeurs
ont polarisé chaque ya beaucoup de gens
qui jouent aux échecs
beau pays la pologne beau pays
fans déçus ce qui nous met très
justifiées même si c'est vrai mais
pourquoi pas en fait je sais pas
cet équidé autres
rax brasc gentil de
me la fait top 10 mondial mancebo quoi
at home dissuader le tennis est pas rien
et bon coupe du monde s'est il trouve
que c'est authier non mais oui mais
c est ce qu ils ont pas un mec qui fait
qu'on connaît pas imprimer les échecs le
truc c'est
donc non je trouve ces tâches pour
cacher qu'il faut prononcer je pense
donc non c'est cool
c'était une bonne nouvelle puis la
pologne c'est quand même c'est pas un
pays où il n'ya pas de sportifs au delà
des échecs vers parents murtagh qui
était le meilleur sportif kazakh non
sans vouloir manquer parce que c'est mon
coach et mon ami mais j'ai en fait c'est
aussi parce que ils sont ils font rien
d'autre qu'un sport c'est géré en
pologne voilà on vient de titres et
juste des niveaux dans deux disciplines
vinokourov il des casaques
rentrent en jeu
christian c'est le seul mec kazakh que
j'ai en tête quasiment quoi mais souvent
le truc pour qu'un accent là mais
qu'importe on a beaucoup de câlins comme
cela qu'ils sont pas des cavac qui ont
été déplacés à par l'union soviétique en
kazakhstan alors que mirta s'il est
vraiment kazakh vinokourov en fait je
pense que c'est un peu comme vlad je
peux même à la vidéo courte mais j'ai
l'impression que
nos pneus tonnes de 15 à 15 c'est comme
galoubet ce super des joueurs de tennis
ou
cd russe en fait
public
kazakh aussi mais pas vraiment faim il
est kazakh mais je veux dire par là
c'est vraiment calmé fin ils considèrent
tout un mur tu as enfin c'est pas la
france et d'autres pays voisins ferrand
et du coup ça peut jouer aussi en faveur
de mme woerth à ce
bon ce soir au dessus de tout mais
oublie qu'il n'était pas là
en fait à pas mal de sportifs russes qui
peuvent avoir la double nationalité mais
comme la ddt et qui quand ils sont pas
assez bon pour être avec la russie vont
avec le kazakhstan c'est un peu le cas
en hockey sur glace
oui c'est ton équipe b quoi
le poteau ses phoques
il peut y avoir un peu de ça alors que
mur tu as lui c'est comme rinat
jumbo
et donc oui qui va dans un pays comme le
kazakhstan savez un joueur du niveau de
duda clairement il serait sportif de
l'année tout le temps et c'est moins que
la pologne en fait ils ont enfin tu en
as it is it et déjà deux sportifs
polonais dans deux sports majeurs
toutefois ces bons
tickets validés quattro qui veut partir
enfin c'est quand même beau métier qu'il
ya un gros buzz en pologne au niveau des
échecs
il y avait des stream avec trente
quarante mille bus amène un gars après
je sais pas trop que ce à quoi
il ya un gros buzz on a beaucoup parlé
dans les journaux etc malheureusement le
pas est vraiment fortement retombée là
je regardais du coup par curiosité
conches en pareil cas ils sont coalisés
1800 1900 mhz /
alors qu'ils étaient monter beaucoup
plus haut puisque les gens sont
passionnés puis après ils sont ils sont
pas restés dans l'ombre fait rage en bd
van gogh ski quoi finalement ils sont
repartis c'est dommage que c'était
vraiment monter haut et le buzz était
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
conséquent qu'en france mais les
retombées beaucoup plus pas
malheureusement mais c'est resté dans le
grand public c'est juste les gens
regardent pas vraiment les complexes et
c'est resté quand même tu vois un niveau
au niveau médiatique c'est resté sait
pas rester dans le monde twitch en faite
en france y sent bien depuis la série
n'a filtré way en france ouai c'est le
seul pays un peu avec les états unis où
ça tient bien
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
mon avis c'est pas grâce à la série que
ça tient coi
sinon ça tiendrait mondialement comme
étant les pays comme la pologne s'est
pris 100 fois plus ou 1000 fois plus
qu'en france retombées beaucoup plus bas
avons peu importe mais tout ça pour
retirer face au losc on parler d échec
de la pologne de tout d'un bouddha et
que c'était une bonne nouvelle il chipe
ainsi juste récompense un truc qui m'a
fait plaisir quand j'ai vu ce matin sur
twitter en plus c'est sympa on aime bien
et n'a joué que nous avec des cannes
blue stream ouais il avait joué avec
nous et eux c'est un gars cool je vais
plusieurs fois en top 12 et c'est quoi
un guennadi calaf chine
mais bon un mur pas c'était sportif de
l'année au kazakhstan j'y peux rien
c'est comme ça
pourtant sa grille et ce prix je suis
une brique de volée manquée par wilfrid
owlient 1
sont pas polonais mais novak et meilleur
joueur de volley au monde
a vaincu d'une fresque 15ème il était
avant le il est arrivé après le prix de
murtazin
il envoie grave qui n'a
invaincu depuis quinze ans champion du
monde cadets en huit ans hyper financer
titre oui contre à 39 ans ce concept un
peu plusieurs peut-être mais
c'est un cubain et ouais ça sonne
qu'humain
ok ok ok il savait que vous puissiez là
tu vois la chance faire la chance en
fait il a gagné la coupe du monde en
battant magnus oui puis tu vois les gens
le grand public le grand public qui sait
pas que la coupe du monde et chaque ce
n'est pas le même type donc à mon avis
dans l'esprit des gens qui ont voté il
est champion du monde d'échecs où il a
gagné un truc équivalent à un
championnat du monde c'est gros quand
même c'est gros ce qu'il a fait tout
dans un moule à gagner un autre
quadra mais non c'est une cata nwè -
petite variante une quête à la m quand
on va dire maintien on peut être pas
celle de la partie des scouts façon on
ne conduit jeudi à cracovie et c'est
vrai que la victoire en coupe du monde a
fait du bruit récemment les médias
sinon saut à skis discipline nationale
avec à we can't stop je sais pas comment
ça se prononce
stach stach j'ai peut-être vu des vidéos
youtube j'ai regardé une vidéo soit ce
qu'il faudrait y saute très bien vrai
gars du 100 m aux énormes états sont la
pologne sont assez bons scores
ils ont faibli b à ba
atteint ici avec les joueuses de tennis
roland garros
une beau pays à bien
sa position qu'on avait il devrait
abonder 7 pas trop le choix enfin juste
1000 fois logique sa dernière pièce se
développer on a un opposant ou bien les
deux donc ok normale et à magnus après
demain ce qui part sur le coup j'ai cinq
compliqué ce qui fait à troyes b qui a
très
bon le truc c'est que deux bases avant
la partie j'aurais jamais pensé qu'elle
reprendre des risques refaire 42 donc
c'est pour ça que deux à jeudi ont
touché 5 peut-être pas mais man
maintenant qu'on a la position mais
coûte il peut faire un 3b quatre saveurs
sen arrive à faire bouger ça qu'on va
avoir une bonne partie aujourd'hui
j'espère
aujourd'hui vrai possible mais ça peut
arriver de tous les côtés en fait
c'est vachement plus trois résultats
qu'il ya entendant par là ya pas
longtemps va être même une heure tu vois
obraniak c'était quoi c'était milieu
droit de bordeaux ouais lille mais jouer
à mettre suppose aussi une
carrière sympathique de rendu des
services à cornet toi
mais tu abandonnes blagnacois
à cornes et au
moins un bon petit joueur obraniak
perquis enceinte et damien perquis c'est
vous qu'on va parler que des sportifs
polonais souhaitait ajourner saadi
fico biac
chat offs qui il est super bon mike
alessi rafale mickael était maillot à
pois rouges
d'ailleurs c'est marrant quand j'avais
fait une une époque je veux pas mal à
football manager et j'avais fini
sélectionneur de la pologne quoi j'étais
très heureux
a juste un petit truc après fou g5 un g6
l'habitude d'y apprendre à me prend qui
a validé cette thématique deux
importants camps oui enfin si non
ok bon fond de jeu par dépôt c'est un
magnus de choisir ce qui part sur le
foot est ce un coupeur
visé nul ça lui fait pas peur
voilà pour le coup plusieurs fois évoqué
ici ah bah oui mais si tu vends des cinq
peut-être que ça va je pense qu'ici si
tu lis dit un peu tout le plus trop voir
success
petite bouffe général quoi
aller ça quand même pour les noirs
fait là c'est vraiment joué sur la glace
noire entre c'est très ténu
site web je sais pas j'ai pensé qu'il
fout g5 quand même
maintenant c'est trop risqué
sais pas en fait je pense que la
deuxième partie c'est la vacciner contre
tous tes trucs trop double tranchant pas
mal
ces expressions n'était pas drôle avant
devenu drones avec le temps
elle avec ce réseau est bien la
troisième dose est
craint rien je remplis dray c'était fini
si vous jugez que j'avais nazis que ça
va
si ces faits files web à la ronde de il
prend plus aucun risque
qu'est ce qui se passe sur un
enchaînement tenu jusqu'à la fin surtout
à lyon mais ce qui s'est passé il ya
trois ans lors du dernier j'ai juste un
départage dans la fin c'est prévu dans
les règles
sauf chez profit
on peut plus
jeux de mots de bons esprits dans le
chat
mais vrai
les amateurs voudront lava marché de
noël tu vois ça peut peut-être pas là
je sens que ça peut te recoudre là je
sens un fab souriant
[Rires]
mais un peu
ya encore un peu de jeu
n est point quelques coups précis bref
toute vie à la position et ça va là
normalement si je vous dirais que c'est
plus facile s'il fait pas d'erreur c'est
rory sinon ouais faut pas qu'il se
relâche pas qu'ils croient que c'est
dans la poche
allez allez les peaux hâlées hadrons et
du goût sidro aujourd'hui demain il y
aura une roue avant la partie a pour
l'instant donné pour peut-être avec les
blancs
signé un magnifique un vin gay dédicaces
et
donc il faudra être là dans le pré live
ci annule aujourd'hui faut être non et
même c'est pas nul mais normalement bon
c'est nul aujourd'hui d'autant plus du
coup de demain qui part avant il y aura
une personne qui jouera pour le vin gay
dédicacé ah ben je crois que je vais
m'inscrire inscrire tu peux te la mettre
le hashtag je vais tout faire
c'est pas un palissandre non c'est pas
un palissandre c'est un vin gay que j'ai
que j'ai signé ce matin avec une
signature assez marrante ya le prêche
aussi qui rajoutera un petit mot avant
avant l'envoi je vais réussir à bien
alors pour les noms sable ça jouera
aussi message aura pour un échiquier en
plastique non ai dit que je tiens de
voyage c'est beaucoup quoi s'ajoutent
pour un échiquier en plastique 100
pièces non dédicacé
on va quitter fait chier c'est mieux que
rien parce que rien n'a rien fait
attaque ajoutant des chevilles mais on s
est dit très beau cet échiquier
d'ailleurs je veux dire
bon - cavaliers incomparable mais
mais c'est bien pour des jeux qui est
plastique il quand même de belles
qualités après le bac est une entité non
stop et tu gagnes je suis obligé
je préfère un score pitot plutôt que
l'échiquier en place non il est beau
même cépage qu'un plastoc grand comme ça
et que
des grands quoi enfin
donc voila voila le petit le petit truc
on s'est dit avec bach sion s'est bien
marré ce matin c'est très belle idée de
ce qu'on fait on a bien les meilleurs
bars ou à nomad bishop 23 en sueur
pendant la game et pourrait bien tu te
dis bon il se sent bien il a peut-être
le vin games a écrit sur twitter après
j'étais pas bien quoi et 10 as a envoyé
un peu il y avait le sait quattro qui
partait avec m bah ouais ça fait partir
à fond loubat qui était pas bien si
c'est quattro par le vin guépard quoi
donc ça nous a bien amusé ce petit jeu
on avait envie de le refaire mon cv
n'est que les victoires de nespouls
blanc
essayez noir
dommage qua non c'est victoire n'est pas
au blanc faut acheter le marshall quoi
c'est ça sinon t'as des stocks
qui
sait si ça devrait échanger c'est ça la
roue de génie j'en ai vu hier des roues
tu fais autant de cas ce que tu veux et
tu fais des trucs
et la tannerie en fait un petit machin
aulas remonte la caisse et de la rue de
la forêt pour rejoindre d'apporter la
fortune
[Musique]
c'est pas terrible et injuste le fou
quoi
c'est pas content en fait de n'être ouf
en fait nous donner des flocons de
lecavalier
la plupart du temps c'est pas bien et
sait bien que si
vous les jeux sur
[Musique]
sur des cases sur lequel est contrôlé
par exemple quand on vous parle des
think of souvent les blancs font pousser
un g5 prendre cavaliers f6 pour enlever
le cavalier donc ils vont ainsi se
défend les cases blanches du centre trop
juste sur casse blanche puisque la
structure pion est fait de telle sorte
que c'est comme ça et noir ont des pions
bloqué sur caisse noire au centre donc
dont le mal des cases blanches donc là
c'est adapté c'est une truc stratégique
mais la plupart du temps
ça en fait
à pourquoi pas mais donc oui j'avais une
clé pour les cinq façons tu viens
de me prend
pas un coup fort au centre
attend et je peux donner bay 5-1
premiers quatre
bons à 6 tiens
ça merci et fatiha si les blancs avaient
le fou de cazin et noir ne l'avait pas
ça pourrait être
le truc c'est qu'on n'arrive pas à
toucher les pions ou à la rigueur le
front des trains c'est une force f5 et
peut-être à des cahiers g5 ou je sais
pas bon mais là il se fout en g2 tu vas
découvrir
mais à vous mr juste fatwa faisait vite
tu meures ensuite
le coup le plus logique même si qui est
des cinq de 22 à ma caisse et si sa
côte nord me demande s'il vaut mieux
conserver le fou que le cas pourquoi les
deux valent trois points à bonne
question en fait c'est l'histoire des
points toute façon c'est juste pour se
situer un façon de vue du jeu ça va se
faire maths donc tu as beau avoir
le matériel que tu vas en moins donc tu
fais maths tu fais maths donc c'est
juste pour savoir que c'est con d'états
d'âme contrainte je ne te faire
reprendre parce que la dame beaucoup
plus qu'un pion en soi
donc c'est plus pour se situer jeu
qu'autre chose et donc fouga vallier
c'est à peu près
à peu près pareil sauf que la plupart du
temps de fouiller un peu mieux donc je
pense ça serait plus logique d'admettre
3,25 pour le foot si on devait faire un
truc comme ça
voilà mais le truc c'est
qu'effectivement il y aura des cations
lequel sera plus fort parce que tu as
des positions plus fermes et à des fous
avec sont bloqués par les pions talent
et position la structure elle n'est pas
très mobile ou voilà ça dépend aussi
s'il ya des pions sur les deux ânes
parce que le chou comme une pièce longue
portée est midi au centre de l'échiquier
joue à droite il joue à gauche il est
parfait le cavalier il met pas mal de
temps pour bouger donc bon c'est pas des
choses comme ça mais il y aura des
positions de castres au dessus d'autres
le choix au dessus juste plus souvent le
fou
c'est un mauvais réflexe d'aller prendre
sans réfléchir toute façon il faut
faut considérer le truc et savoir que si
on le fait on a une bonne raison oui oui
mais là je sais que montréal devra
peut-être pas mais là je fais pas ce que
j'ai lu telle variante ou parce que je
vais rentrer ici août à pluton kelly
pour défendre 3
bon voilà plein plein de possibilités
mais
mais globalement faut pas jeter sur un
kayak un fou mais voilà il doit être
assurée quand même ouais
mais faut pas qu'ils se rassurent trop
vite enfin je crois pas qu'ils se
relâchent quoi sa position va très bien
mais
est ce qu il se passe que valve est
prévue hier soir ben non finalement non
pas du tout il était jusqu au risque
vlad recommandée ar doivent plus
intéressant visuellement a tapé dans une
grande principal de la catalane machin
ça me paraissait intéressant maison
après bon surtout mon avis qu'ils
avaient beaucoup de vies dans cette
position donc c'est nous qui devons pas
à comprendre enfin apparemment
le ventre un dépôt et magnus bah moi je
préférerais que depot gagne
c'est par le préfet je le connais pas
n'est pas en fait je n'ai jamais raté la
parole donc
ok pourquoi pas si vous avez versé 5 et
qui ça
mais c'est pour qu'il ya un petit
renouveau et tu as i am ring son
candidat ça te fais autre chose mecque
du ski va essayer de regagner son titre
là on a un peu le même schéma reçu plus
pour ça mais on soit on dire que le
meilleur gagne quoi ok il veut tenter de
garder les pièces maître sylvie joue
vraiment il faut vraiment l'homme à fond
la ire fait vraiment ce qu'il a fait
dans les matchs championnat du monde
contre allende
il joue il joue juste
attention ça peut être un bon pari mais
ça peut lui coûter aussi comme ça lui
avait coûté contre car yakine faut pas
qu'il en fasse trop quoi bon pour
l'instant ce n'est pas encore très
réussi et qu'il y ait des trois sont
bons c'est fou des six souffre ou b 6
giran b6 monture est là dessus je
partirai là dessus aussi
les quatre peut-être juste te dis bon
qu'est l'e3 il nomme également tu te dis
moquer des trois est pas mal j'ai accès
à la casse et 5 éventuellement
on sait bien que
non mais dépôts va devoir être un peu
précis je dirais
pas qu'ils soient fondamentalement mal
doit faire un peu gaffe à pas le laisser
venir en c5 a pas le laisser faire ci ou
ça
ceci doit être précis parce que si tout
d'un coup tu commences à faire tourner
vite il ya des quatre ça peut vite
tourner aussi en fait les deux doit être
précis c'est juste qu'on a le biais
cognitifs que magnus vous mieux ses
positions là c'est pour ça qu'on a
l'impression que c'est les noirs qui
sont plus précis mais je penserai magnus
au noir et n'est pas aux blancs
d'attention des pirates on se plaint
d'avoir de quoi faire n'importe quoi est
ce que tu en penses c'est possible
qu'il fasse gaffe
ça c'est assez équilibré aimerait bien
peut-être plus de vie dans la position
tout à l'heure parce que l'allemand les
deux ont vraiment des chances
comment
une ouverture
populaire bonjour
oui mais c'est parce que tu viens pas
populaire mais c'est comme jouer c'est
pas c'est pas un truc qui sort d'art les
fagots
après évidemment c'est pas la plus jouée
de tout mais voilà je sais une ouverture
fait quatre jours et c'est là
parce que le granby dame bas c'est une
manière de jouer très fréquente des
noirs sur des 4 et donc ça a toujours
été une manière de lutter contre
ces armes à la catalane classement
publicis logique
tsx igm ouais mais c'est bien mais en
même temps tu as un faux qui sont un peu
qu'ils rendent en profondeur dans la
pression peut être à mon
avantage
il a pas mal de dents dans son diapason
de coûts les russes et a beaucoup de
coups qui sont bons quand même pour le
moment mais bon un moment ça ça pourrait
devenir dangereux
erakat a
su portable via joue bien plus région il
aurait fait pareil
[Musique]
la joue pendant des heures
supportable
tu penses que si on était encore à l'oua
à l'époque où sa propre aux nuls sature
bodereau ici
ça dépend le joueur en faute a beaucoup
joueur qui ferait dans le temps tu as
beaucoup de joueurs qui feraient nul ici
ça qu'on est français
mais
d'emmaüs même pas 6 mm magnus une manne
ya plusieurs années il devrait pas faire
la fête mais d'autrui
oui résumé les parties précédentes pas
tu peux aller sur
youtube et tu vas voir le résumé de tout
parti ou voir le résumé de vlad il est
en fait une une vidéo pour pour trois ou
deux parties mais sinon tu peux tout les
faire une à une c'est chaque soir après
là ce soir en poster un
tu peux aller voir ta bonnet à la chaîne
et aura pour activer la petite cloche
tous les soirs tu auras le résumé de la
partie et tu peux tous les revoir bien
évidemment
f4 après tout est possible mais le truc
c'est comme le disent les femmes tout à
l'heure si les noirs réussisse à
terminer
leur développement ils égalisent mellal
et blanc ils n'ont pas moyens de
l'empêcher bon enfin fiat au toujours
quand même se dire et qui est des 50 ans
aujourd'hui à 5 4
sur les 13 et 15 mai en fait fait fiat
ménard bizarrement placée
sans que ce soit trop grave
ne verra plus songer 5 ou essayer de
même 9 3 pour l'échanger contre l'autre
pour aller vers ces cinq mais je vois
pas trop comment en plongeant retour à
deux dames ici tour ces deux fronts les
deux tours enfin c'est beau mais
beaucoup trop lent ses dévots france l'a
fait kiffer âgés meurent
mais bon ça va jamais passer trop
long ici
si on arrive à 14 euros est-ce que ça
remettrait en cause de frais pour les
prochaines sessions va probablement
passera 16 parties on va refaire 24 en
fait peut-être 24 sept
bah ouais t'as plus depuis le droit de
l'erreur en fait le fait d'avoir
raccourci le nombre de partis je dois
dire que ça donne moins envie de perdre
tu te dis merde je peux plus revenir
sur 24 parties étudient
un moment donné qui viennent
en 2070 sur l'aliment de fait désormais
90 partis
et on réfléchit à passer à 92
et premier à trois gains à leurs bas en
fait le problème du boss y avait un
format comme ça à l'époque qu'ils ont
arrêté justement à cause du match 84
karpov et kasparov alors c'est le
premier à six gains pas trois mais peu
importe ils sont jamais rêvé gagner 6
quoi
ils jouent encore d'ailleurs à votre
marché de la trop longtemps elles l'ont
arrêté y avait 5 3 pour karpov quand
même un huit parties décisives en tout
mais sûr je sais pas combien de partis
soixantaine peut-être pas mais 57 j'ai
en tête mais je sais pas et
il n'y est nulle machin est bon ce à
quoi
c'est logique
et cinq quarts mais c'étaient les deux
coups qu'on avait proposé ici est donc
je peux dire en fait finalement au lieu
de dire le premier attend de victoire
ils sont passés en mode ils sont 200
mode bas on va faire un match en nombre
de parties
j'avais une idée que maquiller pas trop
aimé hier
un peu comme volé à l'époque certains
acquis et noir quand tu gagnes ça ne
compte pas pour un point à dire que les
pingouins blanc qui compte
12 ferait vraiment d'eau vides
comment fou furieux avec les blancs et
avec les noirs nul ou gain ne change
rien ce beau
grandement de jeu
sachant comment gérer ce débat et on n'y
change grandement
à voir si on
çà désiré déséquilibre pas trop le jeu
mais pour le coup dessus il y aura des
trucs voilà il faut ajouter 5 x h 4 tu
le ton bah oui tu en voilà tu cliques je
ne peux pas perdre
ou linverse que les victoires noire qui
compte basi sur un match à rien ça
change parce qu'avec les noirs les mecs
ne peut pas être deux points donc tu va
risquer à chaque fois tu peux te
retrouver avec six défaites aux blancs
et une victoire et l'autre fait s'est
tenue les 7 km toi qui est si ça change
mais il faut en
et avait aussi l'autre idée que tu
chaque jour en fait tu mets comme ya
beaucoup de temps du coup pour les
cadences longue c'est que tu fais comme
au chaud j donc il n'ya pas un vainqueur
en fait on reprend le temps qu'on avait
on rejoue
une deux trois quatre parties sur
récupère le temps que tu avais oui c'est
pas un son chaud qui
ont du coup ça serait pas mal tu es en
cadence classique mais est abandonnée
ben t'as plus trop le temps qu'on n'a
plus trop le temps
tu as plein de manières de rendre sa
mort ça c'est ce que font les japonais
du coup avec c'est pas con
mais jean thomé quoi cinq heures en
début et pas seulement mais par exemple
on pourrait penser aux échecs mais c'est
pour ton match en fait la journée
étant kevin tu rejoues c'était un grain
jack lang
je pensais qu'en fait genre te mets
peut-être vingt quatre heures à la
pendule il a 24 parties la débrouille
toi tu perds quatre ans le premier jour
applique 20 heures pour les 23 autres
bon ça devrait faire tous rêvent d un
tour à ses huit races et un faudra
réfléchir
c'est quand même assez logique de faire
ça des deux côtés
si ce n'est ce pas comme prendre
rires je préfère les cheveux on est bon
non monsieur je vais ce truc insipide il
pense qu'il est un peu plus fort et ça
joue quoi
kasparov j'en ai gagné plein de ces
structures symétrique
non mais
en fait des fois c'est moins simple que
ça en a l'air ses positions frêche on
kasparov c'était pas un joueur de catane
si souvent que ça rien à jouer je sais
dans son match 83 contre cornouaille
parfois il a fait quoi mais mes comptes
petrossian a légué une position un peu
mais bon c'était aussi parce qu'ils
étaient prêts à développer petrossian
dans la partie
électro français éviter tout ça il met
sur la chaîne cette partie elle est
connue il prend direct direct
il veut quoi ils vécurent d'un point
j'avais une idée c'est sûr
tu prends
voir ce qu'il veut
en deux types en cela tout repart de
l'autre côté je sais pas mais dame prend
ça me paraît logique pour lire il
devrait faire n'ai pas
regardé 600 wii et que déjà ça ne
faisait pas trop plein a fait chaud que
cependant un choc et là pour le coup
donc dire oui tiens vous aider il faut
pas donner il faut compter cavale et je
maintiens mais là pourquoi il le fait
parce qu'ils changent la structure
depuis en série se dit bon j'ai donné un
fou j'aimerais bien l'avoir absolue mais
au moins en contrepartie j'ai doublé les
pions dont quelques pions lâche un peu
isolé je peux dès fois peut-être balade
un câble et toutes les attaques et
imagine un carénage 5 1 jour ou quoi
voilà qu'avec 4e 5 comme plan un truc
comme ça donkey
[Musique]
il a sans contrepartie après je sais pas
si c'est si convaincant mais quoi à
noter que s'il n'y avait pas l'option
eux la structure serait vraiment très
faible mais les pions doublé quand ils
sont groupés avec un autre pur à côté
ils sont beaucoup moins fait puisqu'ils
peuvent se structurer ensemble genre par
exemple comme disait pas bon je le faire
fait les pions ils peuvent se mettre en
souliers déjà les hôteliers c'est pas
vraiment faibles j'aime à l'avancé mais
ils sont pas vraiment faible donc c'est
vraiment important en fait d'avoir ce
pion réussi ce qui met du liant dans les
pionts doublé
j'ai pris même si c'est intéressant je
pense aussi mais bon il va faire dame
prend l'or gf que l'intérêt sans je
passe c'est bon pas mais ça pourrait ça
pourrait me je suis sûr que gordon prend
aussi
en fait j'ai pas vraiment
dire que je suis un peu relou mais j'ai
envie de revenir se sont vus disait il
ya une heure vous expliquer que tout le
monde disait que la police eut été
intéressante magnus avec une grande idée
dans l'ouverture et que j'étais un
confort on m'a dit ça camionneurs qui
comprenait pas les nerfs en vrai oui
mais pas étonnant toi tu dis qu'il va
rien se passer mais tu es un con tout le
monde comprend que ça c'est quelque
chose bon ben là il se trouve que j'ai
raison comme j'avais raison dans l'autre
partie quand il a fait car et la 4g cats
ont expliqué aussi par le chat que
j'étais un con mais bon ça fait déjà
deux fois d'affilée j'ai raison les deux
fois quand même temps mais je voulais
lui dire fable on se dit bon c'est du
temps mais on fait passer pour un con à
chaque fois j'ai dit j'ai raison deux
fois d'affilée après la partie peut être
intéressante à partir de là mais il n'y
a pas d'idée dans l'ouverture pour les
blancs
enfin se joue pour jouer
et franchement si les poufs et gf
il en est le slip et le site sera de
taille
allez jouer bah oui mais ça joue
à l'ouverture j'ai donné mon choix sur
l'ouverture
de ce troc et puces
les couvertures à l'est rien donné qu'il
n'est pas vraiment d'idée pour les
blancs leurs sims zélandais et pour les
pensées tout
ouais j'ai fgf ça peut vraiment jouer de
ouf
ces cinquante cinq mois j'attends
vraiment adam prend vraiment ici
non gfi a dit que ça joue mais tu sais
pas pourquoi ne nous la turbine est il
préfère gm qui s'y met
un ordi normal on va dire il préfère pas
particulièrement quoi ça dépend ce que
tu veux si tu veux jouer le gain du gef
mais je pense que tu veux dames ont même
après peut-être qui comprend pas vous en
venir manu ça va tu dis peut-être la
cave a lieu cinq j'essaye de comprendre
la foulée 4 mai
que si ces dames prend pour dame prend
fin mais va tarder à me prend puis je
sais mais de base
quand tu vois le truc vous problème si
tu dis à peut-être n'y a pas c'est sûr
que ça me prend plombant image de cette
finale aller ce qui veut faire torcéen
et si tu veux faire à 4 je sais pas il
ya plein de coups quoi j'aurais dit tour
c'est peut-être mais je tombe mal à
capter le problème fondamental des morts
non mais là je pense que vraiment la
maaf ont fait je pense c'est vraiment
ils se connaissent bien et
[Musique]
bas où
je sais pas je sais pas du tout mais
je te vois même prendre je pense à ça
mais ça c'est plus logique oui mais tu
déclares
ça c'est genre de position
tout le monde sait que c'est nul mais tu
peux la gagner oui c'est sûr que c'est
rien mais
je veux dire je peux comprendre peinture
en m'imaginant de jouer contre des gens
que je connais il ya certaines personnes
contre qui j'aimerais jouer ça au blanc
et au noir aussi d'ailleurs vous êtes là
c'est juste un truc entre eux entre
guillemets je sais pas comment dire
non mais je sais pas enfin
[Musique]
pourquoi pas mais
on va voir
du metagame et ça ressemble à metagame
parce qu'on soit c'est pas
logique entre guillemets
conclusions montrent que j'aimerais
jouer paris si l'époux de touche
n'importe quel joueur quitte la colle ou
pas si sûr
lorsque pas qu'il serait très heureux
que tu ne trouves aussi juste par
principe
au bac il un bon bain technique ces gens
position qui le dérangerait pas trop
mais je sais pas si bas qu'ils seraient
de fer forgé 5 points
blake est un bon pleutre éclairé j'ai
bien aimé le jour un soir où il aimerait
bien remettre au goût du jour le pleutre
éclairé
vendeurs se récréer sa main on en voit
peu plus qu'à une époque on faisait très
peu très éclairé quoi au
brassard a joué
pour les jouets doublement raison
les andains
est meilleur qu il a pris confiance dans
le match n'est pas dire qu'il a vraiment
plus peur
des chefs il faut en avoir une belle
quand même
alors pour qu'on vous dit ça va
simplement parce que le roi noir se
retrouvent plus exposés et que le purin
m6 congés cette évidemment et bars
général quand on a un droit qu'on juge
étant un peu plus faible on se dit à bas
coûts luc g change les dames comme ça
j'aurais voulu être les attaques les
plus forts dans mon adversaire et je
crains plus grand chose
donc pas ces raisonnements qui marche
assez souvent et donc là il accepte
passeront un peu plus faibles tout en
laissant les dames sur l'échiquier bon
gel a dû juger qui était pas si faible
que ça et il veut continuer parquet et
d4 et je pense que le fait de garder la
dame justement cette contrôle mieux la
casse ces cinq il ya plus le tour 5
essais 5 si vite je pense c'est ça son
jugement face à une tellement contents
d'eux n'est pas la gagne au bout d'un
moment tu fais rien avec l'événement
d'ouverture machin et tout
ça c'est cool si tu perds en fait aux
blancs non mais tu veux absolument dans
l'ouverture je veux juste jouer une
position insipide ben c'est beau tout à
fait coller fin j'ai en fait c'est une
vengeance de kayes ça sur l'être humain
quoi je suis deux échecs je fais perdre
ouais mais ça je pensais que six cas ici
faire perdre les départage content car
on a alors fait nul dans cette dernière
position et en fait il était récompensé
par son pragmatisme plutôt
lâcher
mais ce serait beau quand même
mais bon cela dit après gf rien les
noirs sont pas mieux objectivement mais
décision courageuse de la part de
nespouls faut le souligner
le prix de la dalle j'aurais fait majeur
dantec 4 qui peut arriver
tu peux penser peut-être à 1,5 pour
faire des menaces mais bon
bah tu fais caillage car après il ya des
cahiers des 4 tu couvres mais bon là
c'est déjà faux calcul est pas mon
cercle ar 4 siphonner 4 enfilade
m'évoquait f50 je sais pas mais ça peut
être un coup ou pas basa faut vraiment
réfléchir cercle stratégiquement c'est
horrible mais si ça marche ça marche
et décadent norman
hk on aimerait bien mais le truc c'est
que le cavalier va venir en d4 et coupe
la connexion de la dame avec le pion du
coup la dame 7 suffit à défendre mais
bon après ça joue enfin c'est complexe
tu peux envoyer le cash cinq points ici
j'imagine déjà des problèmes de prise et
freud et 4
tu peux anticiper avec tour d'air oui
bien sûr un concept pas si mal
bon j'avoue qu'il y ait des quatre quand
même
la question maintenant oui c'est plutôt
les noirs qui sont non
je pense que des poids après un super
show en danger mais il faut en avoir une
belle
en fait c'est plus son style
d'opposition à lui garde les dames c'est
un peu plus compliqué ça met un peu plus
magnus dans un 3 résultats nuls mais la
pression non mais c'est pas un pour une
fois d'après une décision qui peu
évidente et en plus ne
m'amuse je vais passer attendre faire
que tu dis de façon il va faire dame
prend et du quit en voyage et prend dix
ans ils envoient quand même un gros
message un dépôt
c'est terrible pour le vainqueur
aujourd'hui
peut-être que le vin gay pourrait
partiront cette fois respecter en cas de
nul demain du coup sûr la cam fin et
demi sur deux ou
trois qu'on négocie pour vous un gascon
peu mais
bon il est loin d'avoir gagné
parce que mettre une petite pub non
comme des pauvres cinq minutes à même de
suivre
un rythme tubesque
bon
mais marrant cette partie qui devait
être insipide et c'est les noirs qui
joue bien mérité quand même
ouais mais bon après c'est pas en compte
en rien
un énorme dépôt le 5 avril qui est
décadent du bonhomme bah pourquoi pas
juste 5 on les a on a peur d'affaiblir
les cases mais qu'ayyash 4 tu peux faire
qu'il ya des cadres du coup
donc tu couvres quand même battu l'as eu
4 1 du coup qu'est le cap des 4 tu
couvres mangement lorsqu'on est si
content j'en sais rien mais pourquoi pas
le cas des quatre avec un splendide
3 ça n'a pas marché des masses
en fait il ya un truc l'attention mais
finalement si tu si ça passe jamais rien
c'est juste que tu te fais 1d x long
terme dans ta peau
cela
mais des fois lequel il faut que le
football entre position
en
fait on va dire qu'il ya des quatre
onces et pourrait changer les pièces de
5 c'est pour garder les pièces
bagarre d un cavalier surtout
prennent enfin aussi doux tout autour à
ces luttes à pâtes complètes millions
et mme assad mais des fois qu'elle est
contre fout ça peut être une idée des
blancs
genre tu sais
la finale cram ni contre dit fritz
il est un truc comme ça tu as une
vieille partie de carpes à farges
puisqu'on importe si je comprends mec
comme ça
tu as déjà magnus topalov dont je
voudrais te retrouver ça
comme ça ne tombe pas
jouer un peu souvent ça dure entre
autres pile poil
dur à dire un fab
ouais bon tata ces options là
et pour il a joué solide en tout cas
belle fête de refuge et f
[Musique]
peut donner envie de faire un truc
tu retrouves ta partie non
le 5 septembre très fort mais
là j'ai un peu le bon on va dire cinq
ans blitz je le fais pas déjà je veux
pas fan faiblesse à long terme surtout
je considère que je ne peux pas
contrôler mais avec du temps à la
pendule ça peut
ça peut se jouer simplement parce que
at elle tant que
pas si simple pour les fans des plans
sont pas bien mais c'est pas si simple
pour les noirs en fait peut-être un
petit danger avec cette finale
cavalier va être super coupe et 6 soit
prêt doit se souvenir aussi mais oui à
quelle sauce sur tripoli ce repas sera
pas dans son
poisson
[Musique]
c'est faux aux échecs même avec les
blancs qu'on a l'impression qu'ils ont
un peu moins bien joué ça reste 50 50 je
continue à avoir des idées en fait
c'est qu'elle est et quatre qui est
prend des quatre vous prend des quatre
pour le 2ème à deux franges et de prise
là le cheval qui peut être mieux
c'est quand même pas énorme non non
c'est pesant 2
l'activité est quand même plutôt pour
les noirs non
ouais bah finalement on va dit très
content de te changer d'âme
[Musique]
quand même bien ri car un
bon s'est-il 15h32 à
ti pub ah bah oui bravo à
montfavet l'oeil non je voulais faire
une mini pause du coup j'en profitais
film il pose comme ça après moi je vais
faire le match oui
et que maintenant que nous entrons dans
le vif du sujet
on va voir ça ça doit aller quand même
pour les noirs ça va être une grand
chose mais ouais ça peut être un poil
chiant
aux remarques sa passion pour les deux à
tout moment
il réfléchit en tout cas
on comprend maintenant ce qui veut
éviter et d'où l'idée de dieu cinq ans
fait
du coup tu menaces e4 pour pour faire la
fourchette qui avait les h4 cavaliers
des quatre mais bon c'est pas évident à
jouer parce que ça donne l'impression
que si les blancs peuvent chasser les
cavaliers décade proprement en mettant
cavaillon f5 au prochain le roi noir
sera très faible
visuellement très dangereux mais ils
l'envoient à il trouve les coûts n'est
pas au jour dont il n'a pas trouvé
pardon et des quatre il avait joué un
coup vers l'avant je pensais qu'il avait
trouvé
mais va échanger il va aller dans cette
position peut être un peu inférieures il
a raté le 5
mai on le voit bien sur l'échiquier 1
c'est qu'à valider 4 qui est parti
probablement d échange massif
s'inquiétait vraiment difficile à jouer
c'est le coup de la turbine mais à
kayes et des quatre jouer fabre
et jean guy ce qu'ils préfèrent eux cinq
aussi oui après analyse de la turbine
bien sûr mais j'aurais jamais fait 5
personnellement non je n'ai pas envie
est visuellement mais en fait il se
trouve ça va ça va et c'est s'était
fortement intéressant
c'est peut-être le petit défaut de dépôt
dans ce match on ne sait pas faire ce
genre de coups comme le c4 comme tu
quand même il a un bon niveau de jeu
quand même faut dire mais
[Musique]
le moment où il doit aller faire le coup
peut-être un peu contre nature ce même
c4 je veux pas faire vraiment c'était
mérité pour ses trois éléphants dit qu'à
ce machin et
et je pensais c'était de dire il en fait
quand topalov
vérifier ça a toujours su
je vais checker c'est pas guéri si c'est
pas gagné non plus bas là je ne sais
plus
donc qu'est des cuatro way
faire qu'il prend vous prend damas deux
sûrement
ça devrait rentrer dans cette position
on devrait revoir cette position sur
l'échiquier ça c'est quasiment sûr moi
je pense f5 ici pour pouvoir repartir
par là bas sur trois
abstentions
oui c'est ça qui les colonnes aussi
le cavalier un peu
[Musique]
ça peut ressembler genre de truc
non mais dites bien mais bon après c'est
là c'est l'inversé un peu d'activité
afin
qu'ils aillent prendre des cas qui va
refaire qu'il prend des quatre congé
d'eux ça laisse juste plus d'options
blanc
merci on écoute le ravito souci merci
merci beaucoup mais aussi banale qui par
fab lab
ton travail tu es banane
magnifique ses bananes
on va voir 1
on va voir comment ça continue
jan 10 nuls est bonne c'est pas sûr que
ça fasse plus encore
on va voir
on est un peu de jeu aujourd'hui
sinon demain grave à la rigueur pour
leur gay en plus avec le vainquer
peut-être à la clé un faux projet de
jouer trois projets deux mois je pense
et f5 à turbine est 10 à 5
très bien aussi un j'imagine qu'en fait
elle veut mettre le pion bk de faire un
truc un peu bizarre mais pourquoi tu es
fan faire ouais mais j'aurais peur du
cavalier en c4 mais bon c'est peut-être
un doux rêve
j'avais peur du quai b 2
je n'avais pas fait ça d'air elle change
la vie la turbine est
plutôt en 2007 sur bin
et on sait qu'a t'il fait mal en fait on
fait
ça va il ya bien mais
il est blanc font un théâtre tu fais ça
ça est fou c'est trois oui mais s'il est
blanc four à 4
pas convaincu banane je suis dit que non
mais en fait non j'aime bien je suis
très convaincu d'air
mais ces bananes et quoi alors
banane et audry
c'est pas mal
ça fait du bien non wes rafraîchissant
ravitaille
la néo drieu et
pourquoi pas
mais audry c'est une ânerie c'est de
l'eau dream et ckoi différence des
drisses c'est interdit car l'appellation
un accord mais on sait que ça brûlait
ouais mais c'est pas eu assez duré c'est
la vache la voilà c'est pour ça qu'on
est l'appellation c'est audry pour pas
tromper le consommateur amateur a dû
conduit aux demandes aussi ouais
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est assez bon
l'eau des pâtes
madame b sat ok pourquoi pas ça prendra
un peu de gaz blanche par madame au
centre je regardais 5,6 veut plus tard
ou wes évident
des fois on fait roy là dessus mais t'as
pas trop envie de ces fouilles 3 je
pense
bonne chance qui recule le roi hier
l'arrêt
ça peut jouer longtemps ça en fait
partie peut être très longue thérèse pas
de marché de noël ça sent la partie
longue non
au magnus très heureux lens m'a glissé
une partie non il le test là dessus puis
voilà
mais objectivement savané peau à bien a
bien réagi
buybuy vous coûter la vie mais nous on
fait on pense au sureau saint lô figure
t elle ou
c'est pas mal hein
les filles at-elle
derrière on s'est mis bien quand même
ouais
c'est une autre vie fab
par sion il ya beaucoup de courageux
jouets tout simplement les joueurs
doivent réfléchir longtemps les deux en
fait
en france qui pas mal de coups peut-être
décoiffé gpra f6 c'est vrai mais
c'est pourrait changer de pièce après
comme ça peut-être
là vivante de la musique
très heureux du jour du match mais
je veux dire que quand je prépare le vin
chaud à la maison c'est quand même autre
chose enfin à 8 sans vouloir te décevoir
way back faisant
même c'est que je boit plus d'alcool du
tout
mais oui j'ai eu le défaut dans prépare
à la maison c'est comme le saumon comme
et qui fait des trucs bon en fait c'est
horrible tu peut plus changer quoi ouais
je pars redescendre pas oublier le bouc
ça va
mais c'est bizarre 120 ch je suis pas
[Musique]
c'est pas impressionné non
la chaux c'est bon ça aussi
le vrai vainqueur à dire on va j'aime
bien mais
vin chaud ça va c'est cool quoi c'est un
truc convivial jeudi remet ses fruits
mais si tu as c'est pas un truc
[Musique]
on recherche
logique mais pour en salle de repos
non mais c'est juste que ça t'empêche de
beaucoup travailler de boire
perte de temps perte de temps pts
du coup j'ai vite
bon est ce que votre d'amendé 5 ce qui
est fait à 5 jours ftf 5 5 très bien je
me serais dit quand il fait croire un
jour je veux un rapport vers le roi
là-bas en fait cette diagonale là elle
sera bloquée par les pions
et c'est là que j'aurais peut-être de
leur ville mais de la coi mais bon il y
aurait peut-être dû casser c'est un coin
et non en fait c'est un peu mieux pour
les blancs ça
du coup je pense à me questionner sur
messieurs et
dames ou pas les dom
si t'as pas les dames ici je peux faire
à 5 à 4 avec les noirs tu fixes à 3,2
toujours floues les deux dates le
gainsbarre
avec la dame tu l'as pas
ouais c'est une vraie question difficile
je sais pas si
en gros fois
c'était ça la position clé soit tu fais
comme des projets f mais tu gardes plus
de pièces étaient c'est le truc tactique
avec ça je sais pas ça paraît bizarre
mais peut-être ça va très bien soit
sinon pourquoi alors avoir refusé ça je
ne sais pas car je comprends que c'était
tour c'est un ou l'autre je sais pas
laquelle pour venir la messe que c'était
si l'absence
la position qu'on avait nous deux bases
quoi
en fait
si le sait mieux ça ou de virer les fous
qui avait le 15 mai enfin
il a cette fois été dopés à se faire
[ __ ] en c5 est vraiment tout est
changé donc écoute on va voir le fait
d'un 24 bon il se centralise pas mal
placée très logique pour la peine
j'évite les trois tutela quoi peut-être
futur petit h 5 h 4 un moment
que tu contrôles beaucoup de cases
globalement total 3 aussi pour ça que la
dame a dû elle est mal placé de faim
c'est vraiment une dame de merde quoi
mais bon on a doublé l'avancé à huit
l'empêchent vraiment genre ça ça donne
quoi c'est une vraie question
j'aurais pas aimé riquet fille katia
j'aurais jamais rentré là j'arrive trop
peur
c'est dur à juger et deux tours sans
toujours
oui mais dur je
ris quand on voit le truc car un très
vague dans la pétrole tu dois dire et je
fais rhel 5 5 à 4 et je vais attaquer le
roi et ça va aller
comparativement ton rapport à la petrov
d'hier tu dis que ça passe
ce cadre est dire si ça ça va du ku'damm
ces deux tours c'est 8 c'est fort
bonjour tu peux peut-être attendre
est-ce que même en hausse de 2,6
non mais sérieux
tu peux faire beaucoup de
collectionneurs en fait
bref ça peut-être
solidifier on sait jamais on est là et
peut-être tour à ses 8 est d'autant plus
fort et a déjà avancé
est une question h5
j'aurais pas fait j'aurais eu peur d'un
truc quatre parties moment du match car
on trouve pas ce qu'il a tenté de faire
ça c'était hyper chiant le prix fixé à
long terme
frei trouve que maintenant tu as
peut-être
trop tôt pour faire
mais ça a l'air vraiment égal après ça
peut ça peut se jouer sur une faute un
oui
qui passe une faute aussi de nerfs tu
vraiment forcer nul tu en as marre ça
dure et vouloir trop faire nul si tu
fais le con quoi un peu ce qu'ils
essayent de faire un magnus un souvent
sakic
sa clique mon fab
sakic holt ce clip ce clic écoute on va
voir ça m'intéresse reste au final deux
tours contre la dame pour wealth est
intéressante c'est l'arrêt pendant un
peu ce qui se passe
comme on l'a jugé james et 2 et 2 passes
et logique quelques façons cette dame
radio était mal placé tu veux l'armée
[Musique]
non c'est logique hein mais n'est pas
tout en plus magnus oncle and hell un
pion doublé mais c'est pas besoin de
plus
si tu les dénombrer bastide chacun
sur les comptes
des coûts
oui magnus c'est vrai qu'il un peu
spécialiste en la matière c'est de jouer
des positions qui ont aucun intérêt
fatigués les joueurs les adversaires
les ennuyer quoi en gros gagné par ennui
des fois il ya des trucs il ya des trucs
souviens d'une autre à rognan espagnol
avait des blancs times ans qui est
plutôt moins bien parce que ça aurait
donc la colonne des
puits
bref petit à petit la gagne mais bon
après
comment on dit les joueurs se sont
habitués ont progressé aussi dans ce
domaine là ils sont entraînés pour que
ça arrive plus donc il le fait quand
même beaucoup moins qu'avant
le plus complet voilà il en train de
l'otan des revendeurs
les 80
mais ça me tire
cette
roja réussit gagné récemment dans les
finales qui n'était pas si bonne oui on
des joueurs du top niveau non mais c'est
avec grondona hier un peu comme ça ou
quoi
mais bon vous n'avez pas le choix en
fait il fait la partie il arrive là
dedans juste y donne pas là nul parce
que la raison est d'ailleurs celle été
récompensés
[Musique]
magnus il est comme
il est très très fort pour ça
ouais mais quand même aussi bref ben oui
et non je sais pas comment dire
par 110 mo mois je vais pas commenter la
partie en direct un jésus mais que en
fait il était juste mieux dans la
position
sa part pas une version complètement
égal comme par celles du jour c'est un
truc où il est mieux et rendre une
finale où il est toujours mieux il joue
parce qu'il est mieux mais c'est pas le
même truc où tu commences d'un truc
complètement égal et tu joues tu joues
tu joues tu avais créé un micro trucs
plus un micro truquées et que tu finis
par gagner et pas que si mam et au noir
qui dans une partie normale en avait 1
prend la nuit le améliorer nul très tôt
à partie sinon en fait deux trucs qui se
passe qui fait que c'est quand même très
différent mais on me swing ouais c'est
complètement différent et c'est dur de
défendre un tuk entêtant must win et
qu'après tu fais une drogue qui ne sert
quasiment à rien c'est pas du tout la
même chose en fait
c'est pas chaud le temps pour un dépôt
en 43 minutes pour 17 coups mais faut
quand même faire attention mais la
position n'y a plus grand chose sur
l'échiquier mais révèle un choix
difficile difficile
il a un choix
il a le tour c'est 8 dont on parlait
peut faire peur à première vue mais plus
tu y réfléchis tu dis ça doit aller
et je l'aurais pas fait quand même pas
évident mais plus tu y penses tu te dis
mais c'est voilà ce genre d'actions qui
prend pas en photo niveau ouais mais
sont chiantes cdci
filtre des causes utiles pour les noirs
moi je trouve f5 c'est un coup très bien
personnellement ça que j'aime beaucoup à
ce que j'avais dans le cas tu prépares
204,4 dans certains trucs comme on l'a
vu
cet îlot dam des deux pour dames g5
tu reprends
26 c'est grave mais bon on va le faire
assez vite at il dit à mas
ou l'ordi donne un beau truc
comprendre le geste
envers toutes les tours c'est joli ça
il peut avoir ce genre de piège en
ariège
ah oui même si
on est poli pouvoir aussi
du bluff car ce n est sur six es8
malheureusement être si tu fais tour
séville va venir avec les plantes aussi
une positionner cette possibilité de
sortie ces dames d2
bon maintenant le monde aime pas non
mais va prendre mais bon le truc c'est
que ça fait plutôt peur pour les noirs
avec les blancs tu sais que tu vas pas
perdre ça et avec les noirs tu sais pas
soit tu vas réussir à faire un nul en
force soit tu veux on peut souffrir le
fait que l'on soit pas gagnant ici tu le
sais aussi
c'est pas mal chez pas un tour c'est de
f5
le faire trois ans fait son nid pour ce
retour des uns et
comment s'est
jetée je pense que je fais en fait
et j'ai pas envie de laisser le 3 et je
sais pas ce qu'on peut trouver un truc
pour pas que ça rien
parce que le jeu 3 il se met en place
peut-être
h4 si tu laisses h4 est d'accord sur
tout et pino je fais h4 toi même
tu préfères f5 tour d un f4
paquet
gf1 me sens ok on arrive à ouvrir droit
c'est ce qu'on veut
lâcher même pas qui est le plus en
danger à vrai dire ça je pense et je
suis heureux pour tous passent plus on
ne change pas c'est ce que je vais dire
parce que je voulais en
fait si ta tour ses huit
mois j'ai c'est bon la tour c 2 j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut au trabendo de
mes tours un t'as pas envie
batman en rien donc tour ces deux oui h5
tu vas faire
h45 4/5 cathy pas absente chez toi fc 1
par exemple pour à la main je fais
simple car ils voteront et si j'arrive à
faire ça après ça peut devenir vraiment
3 enfin trois résultats non un résultat
et demi mais
bah écoute
et il nous trouve ça petit dépôt
salaire intéressant mais pas évident à
trouver
nous on a la petite turbine thoracique
très surprenant
ah oui non si tu as vu le jeune ostrava
lucie hier que tu connais ces idées-là
machin est tous en fait il ya une vraie
logique d'ailleurs j'ai proposé 100
turbines est je vais penser comme ça
parce que je pensais à l'émission d'hier
mais après folle pour le faire marcher
ce fut remis la fin à cinq ans mais bon
qui pas forcément maintenant
bas c'est pas forcément moins tu tu
enlèves le pire dossier manger tu veux
aller faire du a4 dubé 4 mais vraiment
dû à 4
6 4
on met les pions sur noir niava du four
b2 c'était ainsi il faut quoi
alors c'est cool bon ça reste
tu as complètement jouable
autour des 1
pour fr3 ouais je pense à toi
bon on reste dans le genre d'idée mais
bon tour s'est dit enfin c'est à dire
moins bon
marché ce qu'on a fait à s'inquiéter
inutile dans le plan qu'on faisait mais
bon peu autour d'un qui util
donc ça serait plus
pour pour jouer autre chose soit faire
un câlin trou de fer f5 écoute faire je
sais pas quel coup pour rien
et tu faire la can mais qui rate
fc vannes d'une époque peut se mettre
dans la merde mais peut-être qu'il est
pas si bien la tour d un bizarre
non
ces cinq par exemple
alors c'est très basses très bienvenu
coûts
chez ba
effectivement toujours correct
complexe
mais c'est pas son type de position quoi
c'est surtout ça
mais pau qui jouent vraiment l'homme
insan ah ouais ben époque il faut
vraiment qu'il n'est pas qu'il se fait
vraiment jouer mais c'est 400 iso
l'homme
ouais ouais partie 1
car le snes j'ai envie de dire c'est un
dépôt qui joue l'homme stéphane qui joue
des beaux mais à l'instar un
[Musique]
bon ça clique 1
on pourrait arriver à 6 nuls ce soir
quand même ce serait beau un petit top
toujours des rêves
tu me reconnais pas été le même genre de
café du monde c'est à dire quand un
joueur de café bon usage pas forcément
vrai mais un jour de café c'est un
joueur qui joue sans connaissances
académiques ça comme ça il ya quand même
quelques unes n'est pas un hacker
quelques-unes
mais pokemon la théorie de 47 pages
pense que s'il faut un concours de
culture de parti carl scène on connaît
plus mais après
ça il ya quand même une culture assez
impressionnante
ouais
imagine tu reviens tai-chi mais tu
n'arrives pas à voir ce qu a joué ton
adversaire ça m'est jamais arrivé ça tu
cherches un son papier s'il inscrit à
noter quoi
c'est pourquoi pas jouer en fait ils te
fin d'une longue mais juste à pire n'est
pas là que
pour les blancos à la casse par as fait
tu pousses
je pense que j'ai fait ce à quoi j'avais
peur de me exposé
je pense t'as pas envie de thé pions
sont sur noir ils sont cools ils
bloquent
pourquoi je crois rouages deux tours
géantes chic
et que tu pousses
tu pousses se pousse pousse
bon
sa clique côté unibet
unibet aide
j'aime bien le fait qu'ils aient deux
pseudos unibet en fait
eu logo
je me perds mon fab et de l'autre côté
il est ce que c'est le même truc il ya
deux ans et mastercard
non mais je sais mais sur la poitrine
droite - du coup
un petit sponsor blanc et un autre
sponsor bleu ou non c'est le même très
gros quand même du coup
ce qui peut pas me faire une turbo draw
juin crise estime qu il a pour lui de
faire ne
[Musique]
et quattro à 4
à tout ça bouffe et b3
[Musique]
merci au revoir
pourquoi pas d'être en mieux que trois
tombes et deux d'entre eux quatre tours
à 3
voir que des pions sur la même elle qui
en est autant espace rien ce serait
magnifique
différence
entre une droite
rien et un bleu et blanc ouais c'est ça
je veux pas dossier écrit dessus mais
les langues
lettres utilisées n'ont pas l'air
de sonner quelque chose que je connaisse
quoi
ne veux pas faire la petite groupe non
m dommages de plusieurs pourtant
l'avocat me échec sonne beaucoup à la
ils gagnent quelques millions par an bah
non plus un
mais pour ce match il ya 2 millions à se
répartit entre deux donc 1,2 pour le
vainqueur 8 sandrine pour le perdons
plus bien évidemment
tout le sponsoring qui vont toucher
ensuite grâce à ça et les aides qu'ils
ont eue avant pour préparer le match
donc on parle quand même de
petits montants sympatico
ça clique
sa clique sa clique
ben
on
a réfléchi côté carme scène
au chili 18 c'est drôle port d'envaux si
je peux y aller perdre oui moi aussi
mais le problème c'est que pour y aller
tu dois te qualifier et là je crois
qu'on n'y arrive pas à quoi bon être
qualifié au candidat il faut gagner les
candidats
pas si simple s'il y arriver mais sinon
pour 800 il aussi joué
il y aura plus de victoires
j'y vais leur appareil aura pas 14 mais
ne t'inquiète pas huit partis huit
défaites devant chez moi mon chèque
sans ville la partie quoi
en plus des sportifs de haut niveau
comme ça bah oui aujourd'hui c'est plus
énorme il ya 50 ans 60 ans pour faire du
sport su gagner autant d'argent ça
répare et le fou mais oui bon après
termes de ratios
je sais pas c'est une liste peut être un
projet sportif de haut niveau mais tu as
des footballeurs qui est remplissent
cent mille personnes dans un stade des
droits télés et des machins je sais pas
aux échecs si on remplit autant la salle
quoi alors vrai j'en discutais avec vlad
et en fait on pense n'a pas réussi à
faire le calcul mais quand en termes de
visibilité
que tu donnes et honoraires de joueurs
c'était peut-être le sport le mieux payé
au monde en réalité ce chèque la boxe
ils sont bien payés mais c'est à chaque
fois un énorme show la salle c'est la
folie c'est énorme georges était aux
états unis pour bon c'est un peu
exhibition de ce thème i was there
contre mcgregor est en fait tu devais
payer jaurès était sur une chaîne
je sais pas mais c'est une chaîne
payante que tu avais pas la télé normal
quoi mais tu devais payer l'entrée dans
le bar juste pour voir match quoi plus
sa voiture a été consommé
non mais je sais mais tu as où je dis ok
mais si mayweather ils se regardaient la
boxe qui ce n'était pas un coup se
rassurent et que le combat a duré 6
heures je te rassure que tu veux c'est
le bar qui te paierai pour venir voir le
match acheté new york et puis bon je te
suivrai bon jusqu'à mal et loire du coup
c'est très heureux mais
met donc oui je veux dire ça peut
peut-être pas beaucoup par rapport qui
prend des joueurs de foot très connu qui
rasa fond mais
ouais t'as ce truc-là de visibilité de
2,2 publique de qui peut aussi entrer en
ligne de compte dans le calcul quoi et
pour le coup ça n'a pas l'air si mal
pics à caen
qui a payé son vietnam non mais pour
aller au barça je ne sais plus mais
c'était n'importe où enfin dollars je
sais pas moi j'étais pas jeter pas dans
la salle du combat je te jeter dans un
bar
ce combat d'ailleurs j'imagine qu'ils
devaient travailler à se fâcher plus où
c'était en fait à san francisco et y
avait un bar qui faisait payer le
trottoir pour regarder le combat
[Rires]
un fantastique
on marche je tourne pas ta john babas
dijoux 14 parties maxi est faux faut
faire plus que sept points dans le match
pour gagner quoi
si tu fais une remarque un demi point ce
gagnes tu marques un point donc loi
c'est comme si tu faisais 14 nature nba
finals sauf qu'il y en a moins mais bon
il faut un nombre impair de match au cas
où
mais voilà c'est ça l'idée donc s'ils
font 14 euros tout à fait bonnes
questions mais ils vont continuer à
faire des parties plus rapide
ils feront en partie rapide y en a 4
après fondé blitz si jamais il n'y a que
10 nuls enfin oublier un partout à
chaque fois et que ça va au bout conclut
égal ils finissent par un armageddon
source à la salle de jeux un congrès
aujourd'hui en fait parce qu'on en dise
avait du bruit enfin ils sont derrière
une vitre et là il ya du public il ya
quelques personnes qui regardent dans
des chaînes on le voit pas aujourd'hui
mais
l'autre fumigènes rien
je me demande si n'est pas il va pas
pour avoir une partie catastrophique en
fait ça peut être une victoire la
carlsson aujourd'hui
ramené son adversaire là où il fallait
[Musique]
voyez donc 6 à 14 nuls et qui font
d'elle un rapide ils vont jouer des
blitz et un nul en blitz ils vont faire
l'armageddon et donc c'est quoi
l'armageddon c'est une ultime partie des
objets de gagner quand elle est blanc
donc c'est tiré au sort et un mec qui
allaient blanc l'autre idées noires mais
les blancs ils ont plus de temps à la
pendule
donc c'est à dire plus de temps ils ont
six minutes et la ronce un quiz en
s'inclinant 4 mais ils sont oubliées la
partie nulle les noirs
champion du monde
on sait jamais jusque là mais ça
théoriquement ça peut
bon c'est pas encore l'inquiétude total
trois problèmes en savate le coup qu'on
va voir je pense que les blancs font
tout pour faire 3 sa chasse le foot des
quatre ça évite les pressions sur f2
j'ai du mal à y croire or bleu nord je
sais pas mais
mais bon je pense qu'il va un chip au
ans j'ai compris
électrique take est il veut 2,3 à tours
s'est vite je pense dame prend pour
prend reese est quelque chose de trois
peut-être non
cavalia vld
c'est parce qu'il veut
par contre 2003 pour des deux époux
premier train
est un mec tu vas tu as un autre tour ou
tue mouches autour d'ailleurs j'aime pas
le droit d'amener l'autre
bas surtout tu pouvais revenir vers moi
non mais non mais il va te laisser le 3
il va se parler sans faute
3 musique
comme ça
va moins bien à force quand même
peut-être dames deux
gagnants f4 f5
bon track and trace à 8 à
4 tours des uns
soit échangé tout se termine à toi c'est
pas de bol il faut avoir de la musique à
trois je suis fier
d'être le droit je suis de ce bureau est
finement
témoin les 3t monory conneries je sais
pas je
fais départ canon à mousse direction et
que les noirs non
un peu
c'est pas super bien joué de la part
donnée pendant mais c'est passé position
c'est sûr que je vais te dire qu'il va
faire trop de coups neutre en fait ils
sont pas trop grave mais jamais il va
jamais tapé la cible au centre
ouais non magusi l'année sur un bond
territoire
on y croit pour le saumon
il peut le saumonade
on va voir parce que c'est vrai que
c'est pas fait des postes est pas
impressionnant
man brosse as tu descends un jeu pas
vraiment dire qu'il est trop fait le con
mais ils sortent pas de coups de grande
classe
cependant sa falaise qui jouent
non ils jouent pas les coûts pour le
moment
il joue pas être grand coup pour le
la demi finale on a obtenu la position
qu'ils souhaitaient avoir il souhaitait
vraiment rien mettre dans l'ouverture et
peut-être si la même pas vraiment révisé
ce matin
ouais s'il a juste beaucoup dormi et il
veut juste être en forme sur l'échiquier
bon c'est comme le plus important ça
peut être une manière de jouer aux siens
voire du jus d'orange à fond était
heureux vitamines cède c'est bien que
l'étincelle dans le soleil talent et
amine d après ce qu on a mis la dernière
pub avant d'obliger ou là ou là là là là
les amis la pub qui par sa part
magnifique
on va voir
oui on avait oublié la pub
on souffle
on souffle on souffle
le casse parfait sur le côté incontesté
des échecs n'ont l'appui le niveau mais
il joue plus depuis 15 ans à 16 ans même
hâte en 2005 alors des fois il fait
n'exhibe il vient jouer un truc mais
[Musique]
bon il ya des restes mais
après si on prend les joueurs de
l'histoire il reste très bien placé par
rapport à sa carrière ça c'est sûr
peut-être le meilleur joueur de
l'histoire peut-être pas peut-être c'est
karl scène et l'autre qui revient en
tête c'est fischer bien sûr peut-être
c'est parti ouais bon c'est pas me
laisser capablanca non mais fisher il
alors c'était impressionnant sans ordi
dida qui est objectivement est-ce que
magnus détruirait kasparov à l'ancienne
en termes de technique vision magnus
connaît plus de choses maintenant avec
tout ce qu'il connaît avec les ventes
d'ordis tout ça
mais c'est compliqué enfin je veux dire
tu dois comparer avec les joueurs ce
qu'ils ont fait à leur époque les quarts
qu'ils ont fait par rapport aux autres
et à comment ils ont dominé ou pas leur
époque c'est comme si on prend bien de
borg et qu'on détient et qui se passe je
vais contre contre djoko autre chose il
serait défoncé mais
il n'avait pas les mêmes raquette
s'était pas leur entraînement enfin je
sais pas et pourtant bien borg si on
pense à un mec peut-être qui peut être
un des meilleurs de l'histoire on peut
penser à lui on peut penser alors de les
voir ce sera aux empires
oui ça se trouve pas du tout mais mais
c'est trop fin pour moi c'est trop dur
de comparer les époques tu peux juste
comparer le mec par rapport à ses
contemporains ce qu'il a fait et qui est
l'écart il a fait par rapport aux autres
dont le titre qu'il a eue
éventuellement
dans l'attitude danse qui dégageait bon
ça c'est déjà un peu plus c'est mon
objectif on va dire mais voilà des
choses comme ça c'est comme si comparant
la plaie avec messi vraiment en fait
t'as jamais su en fait non preuve de ce
fait parler c'est cool
mais
mais je sais pas à quel point c'est
pertinent de faire dans le bus devront
chercher et trouver juste pour discuter
c'est cool quand même une église tournoi
et les faits ça il est trouvée si
c'était plus dur à l'époque et pas les
ordis tatata bon on est très content
mais en fait je n'en sais rien
ackermann
moi je pensais que son goku serait
beaucoup plus fort
complexe
je me ferai fort son
atelier ce pas la petite épée quoi ils
te fais des médias mais bien dans ta
gueule il a où ils veulent il saute bien
ils m'ont brésard je
sais
les chèvres sont beaucoup ils sont tirés
le coup d'épée en fait
il tord est avec un doigt
bah c'est complexe ouais
il n'ose eros l'hippopotame en fait on
sait pas on pourrait savoir ouais il
suffit que [ __ ] ensemble ces
merveilles
bravo ba
qui a fait plus de fois huit
rames en file station
magnifique
y à positionner le complexe ah ouais non
c'est compliqué
il a fait retour des deux ans
moi je partirai sur trois
tours d2
il a donné l'impression touché à tourner
il a touché ainsi lâché faudrait mettre
le ralenti ce que les nappes adoubé
clairement
non j'ai porté pour le jeu serait mais
ici la touche et c'est pierre fut ces
pièces à jouer mais bon est-ce que
l'arbitré interviendra si vous avez un
clip on va on va regarder très avare non
mais là c'est obligé là pour la peine
vraiment l'intention de jouer donc s'il
la joue pas c'est oui enfin c'est pas
comme le jour l'autre fois c'était bien
vrai on sait pas s'il ya déjà deux mais
ça se voit enfin il doit dire en fait
les règles mais ça se voit que dans
l'intention il reposait il veut l'autre
où la densité jouer
parce quelqu'un peut nous envoyer le
clip qu'on puisse ça bien revoir au
ralenti varreddes
une touche pour dire je sais pas à vars
tour super bass et de riyad merci je
pense pas qu'ils la touche moi mais on
va avoir de toutes façons
nom est sur la touche maintenant
les gars zoom
je crois pas qu'il l'a tous fait un bon
jeu mais bon il ya intention de jouer
est ce que
il peut se faire varreddes ce qui a
quand même intention c'est sur celle
arby's de bresse synthé
n'intervient quoi
il ya penalty face à des images de
meilleure qualité et voir est ce que il
ya eu contact
non alors ça dépend comme au rugby de la
question y at il une raison de ne pas
faire cas chez pias a joué je pense
qu'ils jouent parce que comme dans
l'intention il a fait là on n'arrive pas
à voir pour moi il ya intention
normalement il obligé de toucher la tour
que tu vois tu peux ni prouver qu'il a
touché ou pas
enfin votre entrevue même également
devant la caméra face et là on verra
bien on nie l'intention suffit pas pas
vraiment mais là le truc c'est qu'on
n'arrive pas bien à voir il ya intention
de jouer et je pense la question à la
barre c'est vraiment y at il une raison
d'autoriser magnus a reconnu qu'une main
dessus mais bon ça se voit quand même
finir par tout le tour deux hommes assis
le joue pas
moi je demanderais là bas rhin
ont parent
normalement tu doit la jouer quand tu as
fait ça
par messi touche pas et touche pas là
mais c'est ok mais qui me dit qu'il n'a
pas touché en fait lui oui mais ok et
moi je te dis que lala prêtera son moi
je pense n'est pour doit être là pour
dire que la souche et de jeu s'arrête
vraiment une autre façon je suis pas là
je suis pas d'accord non non c'est
l'arbitré qui doit dire dans la règle
l'armée à intervenir sur un piège chez
pias a joué il ya deux joueurs dans la
salle ils font jamais les armes et robin
aubert je viens si bon état le
championnat du monde à un arbre
habiterait du psg pièce à un arbitre par
jour et ça ça mais là il ya vraiment
intention de jeu enfin pour moi il ya
pour moi il doit la jouer en fait il ya
intentions de jeu bouge ta tour non mais
c'est lui c'est juste normal en fait
c'est vraiment difficile de sortie il a
touché ou pas de visuellement je pense
quoi je pensais il a beau tout chaud
t'as pas de preuve matérielle la kiffe
info faut voir les autres calmes parce
que t'as pas de preuves matérielles
qu'ils me prouvent qu'ils n'ont pas
touché
il est quand même très très trash 1a est
très proche il suffit juste des fleurs
et un c'est là il ya intentions de jeu
il ya tout un
situation de jouer que tu touches d'un
millimètre c'est la jauge qui touche les
îles est proche non ont fabriqué une
autre qui a peut de nouveau mais la cam
en face pour vraiment me faudrait plus
d' oncle de vue
mais elle existe cette caméra juste on
avait pu en direct et on n'a pas accès à
l'eau caravane d'armes et salles
arbitres wild il ajouté alors ayez
dessus forcing c'est pas grave mais en
fait c'est pas grave mais si demain un
mois avec les noirs je te dis que tu
enlèves ta dam parce que ça me saoule et
qui sait pas quand fin tout n'est pas
fait c'est une règle en fait j'en ai
marre pourquoi on doit juger la gravité
de la règle à chaque fois tu s'il ya une
règle avec comme ça jarnac à aux
candidats quand les pièces où ces pièces
à jouer les arbitres la force à jouer
enfin c'est pas grave enfin tout n'est
pas grave en fait non mais en fait s'il
a touché de jeu c'est aussi simple que
ça s'il a pas touché a pas touchées mais
ce qu'ils veulent ils pas de la peinture
et mélinda franchement il ya hésitation
fin pour moi l'image allait pas claire
mais pour ça il faut avoir d'autres sont
de vieux
copains sur une zone aussi un doute on
considère que c'est pas touchés
oui enfin il ya personne qui vérifie en
même temps donc il y aura toujours un
doute fois en fait s'il le faisait une
cour où
il fait qu'il n'a pas voulu faire
sportivité aussi super d'accord avec toi
pour le coût énorme et ok mais au foot
je veux marquer de la main puis je dire
que bon bah voilà enfin ça arrive alors
comme le truc de saintes et maintient un
carton rouge un bail court plus vite que
le défenseur va
c'est vraiment la question enfin le
problème c'est qu'il n'a pas les
arbitres au tour je pense qu'un arbitre
s'il est juste à côté et oblige âge en
fait toute façon et c'est vrai que ça
serait bien qu'ils aient pu interpréter
qua non normalement c'est vrai que ce
soit clair et m mais bon on va le truc
clarinette il touche pas à
un arbitre
il a juste à côté
serait un beau petit scandale quoi sebha
est une autre image c'est magnifique on
rails et toutes les images - c'est
intéressant et des images à regarder et
voir avec cet angle de vue on voit
peut-être nous
on
voit mal en fait très très difficile à
dire
mais pâtit il change de caméras juste au
mauvais moment c'est terrible mais
jérôme thion qui touchent pas du coup
c'est vrai qu'il doit pas la jouer c'est
vrai que havret 2e vigueur et c'est beau
quand on fait la barre quoi moi je
construisais je pense pas qu'il faille y
la nasse certaine distance ils touchent
pas la vue aérienne
doit vrai de la pièce il y la touche pas
voilées change ou non ils sont vraiment
moment mais ils savent pas faire un
montage chaise comme c'était
tu laisses la caméra de face tu fais um
et j'aimerais bien comme avoir d'autres
images pour confirmer mais ce qui change
vraiment bien mais là pour le coup on
dirait qu'il a plutôt pas touché
aucune sûreté
soit nous fait deux trois angles
il n'a pas touché il a passé mais moi
j'aurais bien aimé que zizou et attend
magnus on arrête là bonjour au revoir je
pu rien voir talât rabbit qui va six
cabines avec les oreilles il revient
[Applaudissements]
cette année peau qui gueule non mais il
a touché
ce matin genre d'attroupement autour de
l'arabie que les seconds en machin
s'arrêter vocaux fins en tout cas c'est
le moment le plus intéressant de la
journée de labeur est-ce qu'il a touché
pas la tour lvk raison analyses adn pour
voir s'il a bien touché ou pas
à ce qu'on vient de coûts aux gains de
temps on a 24e vers l'a16
est ce que ma mission est simple un
championnat du monde je ne pense pas
j'ai jamais été faire confiance
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
ça fait bien pire donc
kasparov il a fait bien pire
une pièce en match avait fait remarquer
s'est énervé je sais pas la réf mais
c'est possible chez moi enfin après faut
voir s'il avait raison venus ou pas du
tout votre repas la réf
dans un sport il ya des règles le faire
plus il existe aussi les deux miss comme
un titre est en jeu en fait j'aurais
peur que mon itruc de fair-play fait si
tu touches tu touches la non mais en
fait avec question de faire passer une
question de règle du je fais comme tu
veux pas c'est comme si on donne un
penalty alors qu'il ya pas vraiment à
leroy de faire une passe au volley ball
tiré
mais là c'est pas ça c'est que c'est à
vraiment pénale qui sert si tu as touché
il ya vraiment en fait voilà et vous
c'est comme vendre la france a marqué le
second clerlande avec la main de thierry
henry devra dire oui bon fait il n'y a
pas but tu vas voir l'arbitré même si tu
donnes le but il marque contre son camp
à moins qu'ils habitent la règle du but
et extérieur mais bon mais je dirais tu
peux toujours équilibré mais il se
trouve qu'en fait tu fais pas souvent ça
les fautes d'arbitrage la plupart du
temps
d'agrandir bas c'est un fait de jeu en
plus elle se trouvait que s'il a touché
srl inverse en est a vraiment marqué le
but est pour une raison x ou y tue le
rendrait pas ce que l'on sait même pas
pourquoi c'est en fait tu touches tu
toucheras sais je suis passé like i et
iii des comme ça allait bien cette règle
c'est évident que les gens touchent tous
par moi j'aime bien mais je ne savais
pas cette règle serait insupportable
des gars qui toucherait toutes les
pièces tout le temps ce sera hyper
chiant frais des fans de corps en fait
après des fautes et mais qui rendent le
point
avec le hawk eye maintenant
tu fais pas tout le temps mais genre à
l'autre jour j'ai vu un truc
complètement débile
en fait il ya ces medvedev compte
peut-être boubli couche pas qui il a eu
9 1 ce match à faire au filet pas à me
tape ça tombe sur bly qui fait office
riz est en fait double hic il à remettre
sans faire exprès on définit le point
rapide et abattent a parlé pendant les
changes et a perdu le point la parade
parler pendant les changes est lisse au
rythme et à taez points pour public en
fait ça fait maintenant banon une points
parce que le medef a parlé mais ils se
sont mariés 2 mois y avait 40 0 mais un
mais ça peut être une balle de break et
j'ai su que je te dise je sais comme ça
c'est à dire est que c'est le seul où tu
sens bien qui dit pas sur lui pour pour
déconcentrer l'adversaire à faire du
bruit pendant le point ça vient du coeur
en fait il lui faut soit sur la tronche
quand quasiment mai mais c'est comme ça
en fait
réglées dur mais c'est la règle
alors vite
permanence à côté c'est impensable ce
serait normal que la ville soit toujours
présent mais aux échecs en fait faire de
faire des choses normales ça paraît
pas insurmontable en fait mais bon bah
pour revenir sur le coup il en aille
avec quasi sûr qu'il n'a pas touché donc
non mais avoir un arbitre à côté
je suis d'accord
t'as du sud eut cependant tu as vite et
j'avais des choses comme ça mais ce truc
d'esprit de la règle en fait c'est que
ça donne de l'interprétation à tous et
que du coup tu as plus de limites en
fait ça fait l'esprit de la règle esprit
gardin
un moment il ya une règle tu l'as fait
respecter puis c'est tout voilà il n'a
pas touché apparemment sur les deux cas
mais je vous passe à tours et puis c'est
bien il aurait touché il à jour et enfin
au bout d'un an
ce si simple que ça c'est ça me touche
me touche fort vote il n'a pas touché là
je vous paraissent ils avaient touché il
y aurait pas à l'esprit de la règle
wimille a touché il a enlevé sa main
banon en fin
de stage ou un coût non je reprends mon
coup c'est pendant les travaux dits
patrie mais
c'est comme ça
il va enfin on n'en peut plus
je suis d'accord est tripoli moi je
compense comme police et la boîte de
pandore l'esprit de la règle parce
qu'après tu as aussi tous les marlous
qui vont être dans l'esprit pour te kent
je recherchais ouais l'interprétation
quoi j'interprète beaucoup mieux que toi
une règle
mais ils sont pas sur un ring mais c'est
bizarre ce qui
semblait correct il pu faire deux trois
qu'on disait il peut faire des coups
enfin même son tour d2 bon c'était pas
le coup de l'année j'en sais rien mais
y'a pas un drame qui survient six jours
tour d2 quoi
ah bah non mais serait beau qu en fait
oui mais je les touche et est ce que je
fais tourner autour des puits savait
qu'il avait touché quoi et qu'il est
très fermé du coup je ne vais pas
tricher
dit tout ça pour ça rues on voit ça vous
a vu des cinq minutes ans ça fait passer
le temps mais toi des deux camps ont pas
ce qui lui plaisait pas déjà
c'est pas si y'a pas un truc un monde
n'est qu'un papa tu as je pense est un
fou point f ii roi car je crois pas
grand chose l'ordi donne quoique des 4 b
4 à 4 minutes à tout à l'heure j'avais
ce fatal français trop calmes tout à
l'heure aux cimes et a plu car elle est
carrément c4 surtout c'est alors le
cavalier jump est
or dix dames dessins que je trouve pas
qu'on touche aux wallabies de cavale
mais si je fais gérald k stores des
incendies autour du cou je pense
et urban rivals trois vallées bien et tu
refais le clouage pas la tête de sa
5e et je sais est compréhensible berne
veut pas d'en prendre un pot
et du coup tu contrôler toutes les cases
blanches
mais t'as pas fou
je les
volutes
vraiment un jeu de chance aisée
le dessin n'est
pas évident parce que je suis en face
d'une tour et on n'aime pas faire
ça sans loi donc en fait tu vois que tu
met pas vraiment en phase donc soit il
fait autour des 1 et tu fais retour
s'est vite soit ward et aux seychelles
ou soyons revient en dd un très bon
couverture fin de mercato
je crois qu'ils y participeront et de
temps mais bon la nouvelle gamme que
j'allais dire en fait c'est pas la même
oui voilà c'est tout mauvais droite ou
fat robert
gagnon a donc tourné c'est peut-être un
coup de chiottes un
bon
visage sa main que je disais non
mais si tu l'a touché
laissez-vous s'ils vont dire oui c'est
juste que j'ai touché pas touché il faut
que je demande la va mais qui pense
exactement comme nous oui mais il y
avait intention est ce que les caméras
peuvent vérifier un fou non je dois
jouer tour des deux ne s'est jamais
vraiment des 5 intéressant
well autre coup de brigade de lardy je
suis pas sûr beckham aurait jamais fait
d'ailleurs y donne plus un peu étrange
non mais en fait il veut bécane je
comprends un truc en fait il veut ça il
se dit que si tu mets le fond ces trois
assez fort et si tu prend 3,2 à
expliquer quand même et ça c'est
complètement nul
ouais rend un peu plus a effectivement
on met ça va
mais donc du coup on fait b 4 et si tu
fais à quatre
jours et gagner un temps sur le cheval
truc comme ça non mais cats a du sens
d'amd 5 sort très bien et puis si on
peut tu fais un coup alive 5 e juste
envie de faire en général
oui
non en vrai ça a l'air cool
16h34 ouais on a bien pu un peu en
retard va tendre à 40 on va récupérer fa
tsy t'inquiète pas je te sent inquiet je
sais que tu aimerais bien voir un coup
bas
ça vous quand même pas excellemment bien
bon
porter on sait pas on va devoir de
victoire aujourd'hui on peut voir une
victoire donc on ne sait pas autour des
deux c'est quand même pas magnus est
quoi
apple a rendu la
victoire de kim a justement on sait pas
justement
le tour siècle il fait maintenant
ok c'est pas qu'on en fait prises prise
prises d'affaires d'amd 55 à ce moment
là
les quatre
femmes
à part c'est bizarre non
c'est que des choix c'est pas des mots
pression des mauvais choix mais ses
choix
je sais pas pour ça que tu as tu nasri 4
preuve de
ça c'est bien nulle
et le roi est trop frais ouais mais bon
je sais pas où il se trouve qu'il a la
bonne idée les paumés qu'il aurait pu
améliorer bonjour en soit beaucoup plus
tôt soit inclure le dam des cinq
annoncés bizarre on n'atteint pas des
sommets dans ce match
après ça va c'est pas un coup malin
non c'est pas un mauvais coup mais bien
le tour des deux étés way est un petit
truc mais bon ça doit passer un
bon été il va prendre c'est sûr esprit
festival et je pensais qu'il voulait tac
tac tac bk tac tac tac tac mais non
sur le passé peut-être
il va pas faire c'est une idée que j'ai
assez vite un dépôt mais là c'est sûr de
lui quand même
je suis étonné par le coup mais oui
pour 15 coups c'est chaud ça va
sinon tu laisse pousser trois quoi
injuste il ya des bébés 4 qui va
regarder c'est de la romance et donnant
confiance et 2
à l'aller les moeurs sont bien où se
trouve être au chant il te domine tout
petit tour tadam teint mat pièce
inutile
donc d'un procès ait sa part est ultra
logique
mais je sais bien qu'on va continuer ce
qui fait le dam des 5s qu'il a une autre
idée je sais pas moi j'ai flippé année
1 est-ce que c'est hors france évite
papam et f5 moi ça pue le 3 avril
qui a
sondé casion sa terre
il va se mettre en place
bref pas faire ce vol 1 h 53
venir et machins et on sait pas
pourquoi ici au tour d'amd 5
bkc telle idée quant à là
mais ça va pas être mauvais mais c'est
juste que c'est a l'impression qu'ils
écoutent je suis un peu comme la partie
numéro un appel c'est pas de lyon y'a
pas de liant et ni d'un côté ni de
l'autre c'est un peu bizarre
a pu boire puis à
rattrape à dos
mende cavaliers c5
j'ai pas et magnus ccbe c'est ouais
je le sens tellement pas normal je me
demande vraiment faim oui
dépôt y eu
voilà au pire c'est
adam prend part à
tout repenser à tout ça oui mais
les blancs sont pas trop plu même
juste faire d'un médecin que je pense
enfin il fait d'armes français vitois
niveau qui va revenir tu vas prendre
et va prendre ma news va reprendre et il
va rejouer tempo presque normalement il
a et donc voilà ça nous devrons aussi
offert le dôme de 5 là je pense qu'il va
prendre et si on revient à ce choc au
sommet pour le dessin dommage qu'il ait
pas eu dans l'autre sens 125 c'était
beaucoup plus voir ouais
y'a vraiment nous échappe pas dans ce
match
logique
on
confort s'il est trop confiant un truc
aussi compliqué non mais
c'est à l'encontre
du trésor
au lieu d'être vraiment faire mieux en
fait trompé
[Rires]
en mission c'est de faire nul connais
vos
amis par port des 4
ans sur avait malheureusement pas faire
qui enfin va faire causer toujours
à bab un mois qui
[Musique]
est tamponné pauvre
rondepierre en fout quoi
je
on va sur sa wii ci est ce que ça peut
peut être se démener podhale est fixé à
assez logique en fait
on n'a pas foulé de alors pas encore en
forme et en reprend et qu'elle prend pas
possible et ça se ressent vous comme eux
trois tas foulée de vin
est très heureux que
vous prêchez un basson monsieur salaire
à une amélioration
madame verdun baie trop être bouffé quoi
une idée là il y les chocs
donc fait
non mais c'est pas avec les blancs
l'impression un peu
pas trop des pièces
mais tu sais quoi peut-être que ma guise
ouais mais c'est pas grave je vais
travailler de l'autre côté un peu on va
voir
et c'est que peut-être trois des quatre
jusqu'à saillard tu fais b4 après étape
le fou mais dominés 2 5 à 4
bah c'est pas aujourd'hui à partie être
en vie
mais on est poli
j'ai pas ils essayent un peu con
way j'ai l'impression qu'il prend
confiance au fur et à mesure du match
avec magnus est pas impressionnant donc
tu prends confiance à force on n'était
jamais dominé il ya aucune partie était
mal ben tu te dis bon écrit notre garde
nostra vladut sont annonce des variantes
que tuvéri le mec tu sens rien enfin bon
puisque tu regardes nasrallah 200
personnes mais les deux personnes enfin
elle a programmé sa tour de défense sont
pour cce et tour à 2 pour les touts
barricadés dans cessé de leurs dames
baies 3 5 ou
alors ils aiment bien les blogueurs
rosie dame b 3-2 ce qu'on veut faire
torrado on va dire
donc on s'en fout c'est là bas
pas si simple de pièces
recyclées non
reprises pris ça c'est quoi le rapport à
prendre eh bien on fait quoi
bon le fait
tiens
c'est bizarre en fait opposition la dame
est bien l active c'est dur de faire des
menaces je suis pas du tout cas il peut
être agile du pc et
enfin tu souffles quoi
[Musique]
au revoir
ici
c'est ce que j'allais voir sur le
téléphone c'est très dangereux quand
même ce café n'est pas le truc avec le
dam des cinq d'abord c'était cool ouais
c'est bien oui mais 00
c'est son fou tu m'aider 002 partout
rien qui l'intéresse c'est iggy prédit
la victoire des blancs des blancs
il fallait a prédit que de la merde
depuis début 20 nous on a prédit que
dénuée que des nuls à l'huile après des
victoires
c'est pas dans mes dépôts juste étonné
qu'il ya ici vite là dedans qui part à
d'autres cycles a
jamais fait mais bon
pourquoi pas
après c'est vrai que tu peux aussi dire
que tu auras toujours un père pète un
truc aubin pas si clair comme
un mois
si je prends des blogueurs je sais pas
en fait
j'avais plutôt dire blanc mais plateau
des mulhousiens salaires coule sur
bouger avec les blancs mais en fait tu
arrives à te mettre à quatre tours tu
défends un peu tout c'est un peu les
coûts de cavaliers
donc ouais battre les blancs cela
peut-être plus simple
la première impression finale
ils sont ps avec le temps restant parce
qu'ils veulent
que pièce à jouer tout à l'heure on s'en
fiche complètement mais bon comme tu as
tellement rien à raconter tu es deux
raisons on vient de le plan très grave
tergal à + 12 minutes c'est trop
facteurs importants pourraient faire
partie
c'est vraiment le facteur décisif qui
al'avantage marquant quand même trois
fois plus de temps
est-ce que carlos à notre mesure trouver
des cours rapidement
c'est tellement plus
on est passé en dessous des douze
minutes
magnifique
non mais je trouve absolument pas
sérieuse mais ça ça par contre là pour
la peine mais dans le
body language
schéma de maths côté noir attention
complètement et dangereux
voici les normes pauvreté et roll oui
peut-être l'option arrivons à vache ou
s'il va voir avec seulement 10 minutes
à trois danseuses oui à toi tu ne fais
pas tout à fait assez pour toi / cases
noires en daim fougueuse morne à la dame
donc les risques
on veut faire ça venait d'angleterre
mais je crois qu'il veut 3 c'est pas con
parce qu'il a touché
à sa fin a ralenti et où
c'est en fait il était vraiment à deux
doigts touché le pion c'est vrai que
j'ai coupé notre offre b2b
france faut vraiment l'avare aux échecs
en fait
du bialé en moto il va le faire
il est pas serein parce que dans une
partie tu fais pas ça quarante mille
fois d'être à deux doigts touché tu le
fais des fois une ou deux fois mais il
ne fait quasiment à chaque coup
quand tu lis ge hockey en plus il fait
que rattraper le pion à le faire tourner
ça traduit vraiment
une tension
croît chez une parente marrante le 3
mai a priori rien sur fougue il ya qu un
coup ses tours ses
500 fait tu veux jouer la même avec
tomber deux dames des traces et ça l'est
moins dans ses 5 avec la mieux placée
des pattes blancs
derrière
toi ta
carrière et je chaque nom
ah ben si tu perds un pion un
et monta toujours des pertes
non convaincu la police mais
bon je passe à autre chose que fout b2
pour le coup j'ai quand même fait gerber
devrait pouvoir faire une un blanc sont
pas en danger au final trop ça
c'est cool ah bah oui
on est d'accord coppola gus c'est la pls
il appert bien il apparaît bien là dans
la terrasse depuis le début de ce match
alors qu'il a affiché une grande
confiance tête il bluffé en fait un
avoir la gueule de bois après oui là il
a peut-être des problèmes de santé ça
arrive vous faites assez fréquemment
dans des matches où quoi qu'un jour des
brûlures d'estomac cause du stress nous
relève de digestion
c'est les matchs son nom sur 21 jours
être malade dans un truc où tu
travailles beaucoup c'est assez commun
en fait
dsk
un full cinq jeux plus normal pour faire
d'un bébé trois
genres apple est ancien et dames serge
donc faut 5 tours 5 deux médecins
qui fait
tomber 5 9 à 3 ok mais ça c'est bien
damas trois façons pour
7,4
chance
s'appelle
trop grave pour les bonbons au feeling
comme souvent avec ce rapport matériel
en fait 300 pages dont quentin du droit
est pas ultra sécurisés ont réussi à
trouver le contre je
vise et la pub
bientôt
je pense un jour ou l'autre d'avoir une
victoire quand même dans ce match les
deux joueurs ne sont pas assez bien joué
pour faire que des nuls pour 5
et 10 policiers faire genre ça et
revenir au truc d'un pion autres
je verrai ce que c'est grave ou pas ma
nature voyez là il est plus défendu
sa chanson ktm tu peux être mal avec les
noirs quand même si j'ai trop le con way
bon là dessus et frise tour des deux
dames c'est un rat bouche de métro et je
crois que quelqu'un mais il va pas trop
bouger
et bon tour ces cinq sets assez
convaincant
bon je te comprend 4 1 mais c'est nul en
fait
qui monte
cette chan pour les mars en fait pas si
faire ça
à l'air bien ça pour les blancs
phocéen capallere d'étape
thor c5 dame betty packard est libre et
tout ce sont 1 but a redonné un sens
quand même truc
f3 non
alors ça bon menu
attentes et
non mais dès que tu montres premier
jacques
henri iv
2 3
ces quatre
chèques combat
c919 clash pour gagner opening et george
harrison que juste avant c'était les
noirs qui veut pour rien
ouais en fait c'est encore un coup
peut-être un peu c'est pas dur à dire
sept minutes pour magnus
avec un nid françois jacquier peut-être
d'un machin d'un proche d'un match 5 ok
peu d'autres
dont il ya probablement des choses oui
on sent qu'il ya beaucoup de potentiel
de nul des deux côtés
ce qui fait plaisir
je vous renvoie mecs de phase peut-être
retouches détruit coupin
entrée je fais beaucoup dans cette
partie honnêtement
je quatre
voleurs prendre c'est la même chose que
tout à l'heure et casques à son club
on
sait très bien
mais
hk très bons coups il donne dinars pour
son roi
il est poli la place
pas si simple dans ses positions
ça semble que chaque coup ça tourne mais
là ça tourne plutôt pour manu way plutôt
une séquence qui lui est favorable ouais
pourquoi ces bons h4 nantes juste pas
déjà d'une case age 2 pour tondo perpète
dans une case où tu fais mieux de cachet
et tous les ventes tu vois ta leur
monter les deux tours sa septième on
prenait et le roi est un peu dans la
merde h4 c'est bien si tu faire des
échecs sur h5 tu peut le pousser loin
défendre une tour faire des maths
d'escalier donc ok je 4 sympa
rires fous et cinq thèmes
bafoue les deux sûrement encore jouable
une photo ratée une fois
sur la mamie en fait c'est sa gamme
d'ici ce temps les deux dames va changer
le score 17e qui te
font chier quoi
c'est fou d'avoir raté tout à l'heure
c'est moins net que tout à l'heure avec
h4
bon volume
desroches ça change rien on va quand
même revenir attaqué au
braille te dis assez fait que tu as deux
bons coups c'est fou hein ou faux b2i
tous les autres c'est plutôt mais pour
les blancs
c'est vrai ça se fait mais voilà
assis peuple s'en prendre à lui-même
grande
puisqu'il adam des 5 mai le fed en
contre sens et les flots 5 au lieu de
doubler deux il donne un cours gratuit
c'est le défaut de dépôt et dames b3 du
coup le problème c'est comment tu vas
mais c'est la même en pire avec ton
c'est ça retour sur six ans
damas 3 mais ne trouvait pas dans notre
genre on veut faire un
tour des 17 et sheba ont su quoi lâche 5
lorsqu'on se prend alors de
la troisième
place alors dit hyper confiant pour les
blancs
tu peux le prendre ça
on ça fait tellement peur de rentrer
là-dedans
belle façon de chaque fois de faire
bouffer en cinq ans trouve en mer dont
9,6
on va donc aller libérer de rien
six cavaliers prend et d'apprendre à
savoir la tête donnait pas d'issue
et pas passionner l'école ouais mais
vous voyez passer via la perdre c'est
fou quand même
assez grotesque grotesque
passe moins bien d'après cc je pense
parce que j'avais vu d éval bon après
[Musique]
h5 en soit c'est logique il faudra
trouver de la première fois gère pas là
ouais bon temps à 6-6 mais toujours 0 0
mais bon
mais plusieurs zéros ne te dis que tu es
plutôt un peu mais je veux bien le
croire pour ses 5
0 avons
dû changer d'avis en fait ça descend de
plus en plus mais tu vas faire tour ces
cinq dames b3 cavaliers e51 les tours 17
donc c'est ça tout
ok à 3,17 ouais ça ressemble un peu à un
autre truc dame prend b4 quasi la part
de thales ou étrangers 80 on peut plus
aller en soit eric à tanger
4,05
enfin je sais pas c'est juste pour
tester
et donc à j-5 pas mal joué quand même
karlsson demain et peut-être unis va
nous jouer un petit rouage de
bien mettre l'euro sauf ici après
acheter un courage mais ils essayent
fait passer en même temps parce que dès
que tu prends de latence la dame sur la
deuxième étape eu la tour tu nas
directement père fait et pas forcément
plus safe non tenues des échecs des fois
même tu gagnes pas vraiment à temps si
je suis fait dam des trois là et puis on
prend
notre dame b2 ont su passer l'onctueux
retouche le truc c est quand même ouais
mais on soit tous sont touchés oui mais
tu touches mairie je touche et je touche
ça aussi
c'est à dire que je vais expliquer aux
gens
g2j maintenant j'avais 4 aussi pour
défendre fait madame elle peut faire pas
mal de trucs ici
wen ajoutant dans dix coups mais la 4e
minute pour carlson pour dix coups ce
vote en taule en rigolant là en fait
c'est une position autant envie de
calculer comme wikia pas les 30 secondes
par coup il s'est quand même important
donc en fait c'est vraiment quatre
minutes skype et trente secondes plus
tard une neuf minutes en est là c'est un
facteur pour le monde pour le foulage de
récolte fut
alors seul orgueil mer mais c'est
bizarre de la part de nespouls de se
barrer
c'est bien le temps de réfléchir
nominé poli trop stressé prestation
ouais c'est ça c'est le stress peut pas
tenir
mais magnus il est très hésitant et la
paix il n'a pas l'air d'être fc seraing
non plus
ok ce qui doit être un moment chaud ici
pour de vrai ce qui est vrai que les
deux joueurs n'ont pas l'air super
précis dans cette partie à beaucoup de
tension qui est en train de
d'augmenter c'est pourquoi dame prend
des trois picos copie
d'affaires wild pas raison
mais tu vois la fin ça fait celle à six
ou septième fois en une dizaine de coups
qui hésitent quoi
tient pas c'est quand même c'est pas
commun en fait de voir sa visite à
chaque coup surtout avec aussi peu de
temps die welt chacun va être
bon mb trois salaires quand même normal
l'expérience ça qu'on est inquiet mais
c'est qu'un monde et si tu as besoin de
calculer link est à 45 je l'avais pas lu
oui j'ai vraiment l'expérience tu sais
oui bon on va pas se laisser tomber sans
bouger la césure non le fait qu'ils
jouaient les coups ça on est au courant
toujours très partagés ce petit avec
deux tours contre la lame c'est quoi la
théorie normalement deux tours c'est
plus fort mais après un facteur très
important c'est la sécurité du roi des
rois en fait
pour les deux sont plus ou moins qu'ils
veulent on
croit vraiment dans la merde mais la
dame elle active allée centrale peut
s'incruster en f3 en b3 attaqué des
pions
on et poté ou quoi c'est n'importe quoi
c'est vraiment n'importe quoi le trap
plus de temps tu reviens pas rapidement
faire et c'est
le stress fab ça fait faire des choses
irrationnelles
on doit mettre la dernière pub avant le
design ça on est tranquille après
le monde est tranquille après
une erreur de ne pas rester à la table à
ce moment là ouais en fait c'était trop
stressé écrit un mot qui a toujours nos
tours et quand il joue tu reviens et tu
perds trois secondes ça c'est pas grave
et là il lui a filé deux minutes quand
même
n'importe quoi enfin deux minutes c'est
plus de 150% du tombe comme ça moi
je m'en bat mois plus tôt avec les
plombs après il semble que ce soit juste
nul en force dans les ventes convoi avec
l'assistance jordi
mach 5 ça soulage et marées tiens des
villages s'agit de se prendre la marée
de pions leroy et laura passage pour se
barrer donc ça commence à faire beaucoup
de choses qui sont
[Musique]
du roi jeu de kasparov fine il a
vraiment fait fabien tu sais radâmes b3
parisien
c'est beau c'est exact b 2
je pensais dam des trois tours sète
saddam
on june est paumé où il faudrait qu'ils
jouaient pas
et on dit qu'on a vu
et trois ans les amis ça paraît vraiment
le coup logique après il peut de
chocques avoir peur et faire d'un f3 fin
c'est un peu irrationnel selon moi tout
à l'heure donc à madame f3 oui mais bon
on a vu quelqu'un mais il faisait beau
fils qui vont pas trop faible des stocks
est de prendre le taureau ces cinq sa
perte d un acte tout perdre quoi
oui mais
où 5 c'est pas terrible
souffrance que vous soulevez là je crois
que ça va toujours trouver des
semences et d'amd 3 ici dans le lion
c'est d'amener trois gemmes et d'oléron
mais quand ya pas de lyon c'est pas car
c'est laissera main mais pas étonnant
qu'ils soient sera maintenant magnus
n'est pour
nom n'est pas sur un agresseur a nourri
les poncifs
d'avocate pour dames 3 4 il te prends le
5ème
jose en fait c'est un peu lente qu'on a
vu de telles armes et tapas gagnon à 3
alors après ça se trouve c'est pas si
grave
mais bon
écoute tu te tapes a très envie quand
même quoi
bon
les fêtes tranquilles
passerez peu
complexe
car ne vous faire réfléchir karlsson ou
bien ils essaient de voeux le meilleur
dans ce passionnant mais là en fait le
temps c'est un facteur sans en être tu
peux pas dire avec mes projets jouer de
la merde parce que les coûts ils sont
pas si dur à trouver une norme mt
renforcé ça va aller en soit si vous y
rendre il fait nul il peut être bon
parce que j'ai pas autre chose s'ils
voient que c'est aussi nul mais que
peut-être il ya un piège ou qu il peut
tenter suis là mais il va pas se [ __ ]
mal exprès pour dire ah tiens je vais
retrouver
ça il va pas le faire 30 minutes c'est
quand même beaucoup imaginer que va
toute décision aussi à tous les buts sur
deux choses comme celle de trois minutes
à la ja de fou honnêtement un la mariée
antimine dam des trois quarts ayew 5
c'est pas le coup le plus dur si on
prend un tour c'est cet effet tempo d'un
point à trois tours 17 dans les deux cas
tu peux déjà commencé à répéter
peut-être
après tout bref cinq ici c'est peut-être
ça qui peut tenter
des sports
et puis peut arriver dans cette fosse et
se dire que le piège c'est que sur tours
g7 si c'est un piège varois f5 dont j'ai
54 ans h5 ya trois mois il atteint
problème de aussi mais je vers l'option
fils
donc ça peut ça peut être
être l'idée lâcher ben c'est pas si une
astuce vous pouvez retrouver aussi qu'on
en fait
[Musique]
ça bien pas de lire en fête passez moi
qui me disait tu lisez aussi
comment le disent car on lisait un
manque de lyon
mais c'est pas ça c'est parti
quand on a l'impression que c'est un peu
chaotique
l'art est pas sûr que nous pourrons de
la dent on sait pas
aujourd'hui se passe un peu plus quelque
chose que les autres jours quand même
grâce au show d'ouverture
ouais en fait tu veux pas réciter battu
truc
à vrai dire hier ça révèle par ailleurs
fait six arrivées potentielles de belles
parties
mon cas
on peut changer la posture
mais pau calcul
ce n'est pas tout
niveaux
bas annonce qu'à tout peut arriver
ils ont tous les deux raté plein de cash
game pour drouot instant t et la
maintenance est chaud
il n'a pas aidé avec magnus il devrait
aujourd'hui or vu de la partie je pense
pas qu'ils puissent être deg pour que
personne ne sera ni heureux ni déçu du
nul est
juste normal way est juste normal oui
c'est juste normal nul mais après
pas mal c'est une position il ya
potentiellement une gaffe qui peut
arriver oui puis le temps le temps passe
de parts et d'autres un magnus à 3
minutes nespouls 15 sans grand beaucoup
moins six tueurs a pu encore 10 minutes
sur ce coup un moment bon c'est un peu
manqué c'était le chantre deux coups qui
ont leur équivalent
donc avoir raté les occasions pour tout
risque aucun des deux ne veut aussi
fascinant non c'est pas ça c'est qu'on
est les deux pouvaient avoir des
positions où c'est uniquement poussette
et ils ont raté des occases et de côté
surtout d'amd 5 de nespouls en fait je
dirais un petit peu avant qu'ils
pouvaient mettre un peu sous pression
donc ils ont eu tous les deux des occaz
pour
pour jouer petit avantage tranquille
toute
époque magnon sarre et en fait
équivalent
m fougueuse et fouad maintenant pour ce
5 le tempo en magnus je crois pas donc
il a vraiment raté tout à l'heure c'est
fou
c'est une grosse connerie en vrai nom
mais quand j'y pense
juste pour montrer en fait tout à
l'heure
quand il s'est fait attaquer le fou par
trois il avait foulé 2 qui était très
fort mais qu'il suffisait pas pour
gagner mais qui était fort il va faire
flouer 5 du coup il va laisser h 4 h 5 3
2 lots sont maintenant plutôt en faveur
des blancs ils ont caché des rois il
fait maintenant foulée 2 mais ben il a
fait foule 5-fu b2 il a perdu un tempo
donc il a vraiment juste raté l'idée
tout à l'heure à priori
très étonnant c'est étonnant à ce niveau
de la compétition
c'est sympa hein ces
gens disent que c'est une gaffe on va
aimer plus de 72 à et ben voilà
ah oui d'accord mais la connerie avec
claire c'est tour ceseda mettant le
pourrai d'amd simba et le cci fait dame
17 rue d'ham des 600 m mais on tour
cessé de vous prend à 3 n'ont cessé de
la 3d sortent tour a nommé sa marche
plus les verts un truc c'est que notre
notre turbine est trop nul
face à croix
mais la suite fut en fait non
enfermé le fou
c'est grotesque bas bondam décide c'est
quoi le problème de ces tempêtes
et 10 h 4 h 5 mais il aussi appelé tours
5 il a dû rater ton c'est ce à quoi
allait sa santé qu'il était stressé de
par mettre la pression c'est magnus qui
va gagner
vlad a toujours su
impressionnant
ça peut être fin du match 1 d'ailleurs
mais mais c'est quoi le pour la mission
votre jeu je la fais à comprendre bien
un problème je comprends que c est plus
fort que stordis la
regarde
dur a expliqué là ce qu'il a fait c'est
mental c'est mental est là quoi dire en
fait ce qui fait le dam des cinq à
contresens il rate le four b2 il le fait
après lui même là tu avais encore le
dôme b3 qui te fait nul quoi et à ses
fins c'est facile vous avais pas très
dur en vraie
série de coups mauvais ouais c'est
mental en fait à bien jouer magnus un
effet craqué mentalement bon après faut
confirmer à partir je n'ai pas encore
compris
oui mais bon dans tous les cas il avait
pas tous ces cinq sinon tu rejoues thème
prêt oui mais pas au retour 5
impressionnants d'hier qui voit rien
quoi ouais
regarde comment la chaise elle tremble
fab
ça c'est vous il a vraiment juste raté
alors
les 2 %
d ici c'est calme logique d'un des six
chanceux doit faire
même des six tours ccl2 est toutefois
trois
cavaliers f4
dame prend des quatre tours 17
est
fière d'être la merde et on voit que tu
vas te faire mater
dassier prend aussi su masquer proches
c'était là on voit que t'es super qu'on
aura laissé rouages de ce top adonne
bien oui
c'est incroyable
est ce que si faire fonctionner pau va
craquer dans l'approché de son pense que
oui fond c'est fini mais maintenant
c'est fini ce que le truc c'est que dans
la précédente il a raté le c4
et la fin c'est ça fait penser au niveau
des partis que gagne alireza sans
vouloir
tordre et un raté aussi incroyable
ce troll
attendait à ce que c'est si grave mais
il dit que les leurs sont bien beau
monde il y faut prend à 3-3 7e qui c'est
un commentaire les amis à seniors ce que
le niveau de jeu famélique
assez terrible fab c'est la tension les
deux joueurs ont complètement craqué
mentalement
c'est incroyable a dit qu on garder chez
lili chopra 3 il veut te reprends b5
c'est évident et il te dit tu fais juste
d'amd cette attaque les tours il ya ça
joue femme ait dit qu'il te dit dame 17
parce que tu attaques la tour si elle
des fonds publics a tu le prends
clairement et et sur un point comme
tours bautista le temps de faire baisser
cette attaque la tour tu vas tout
infiltrer les amis c'est un couac ce qui
se passe bon c'est pas ce qui va se
passer quoi ça peut faire des conneries
dans tous les sens assez incroyable ceux
d'amd cède ce qu'ils veulent trouver je
sais pas moi c'est facile je leur dis
comme ça leur donnent quand tu es dam
des six mois je voyais pas le problème
ap j'ai compris ça battle c'est écrit
sur mon calendrier ce battle aujourd'hui
c'est
joue contre les norvégiens aujourd'hui
femme j'ai compris j'ai compris ce qui
se passait
baron fou avec les blancs contre il
donne au noir alors voilà mon job une
belle partie qui se lance on avait dit
qu'ils auraient plus de sabadell pendant
romand finalement elle est là haut c'est
magnifique
par contre niveau n'a jamais été
perdants au que si haut que si bas sur
l'autre ligne c'était finirait avec le
fou envers l'autre mais c'est dur à voir
peut-être je sais pas pour dire c'est
moi je n'avais pas demandé si je me
questionne agi mais pourquoi cci est
tellement excité quoi mais
je vous répond j'ai regardé la turbine
mais
la faute était dure à détecter quand
même pas fou et 5 es fou b2c à
contresens a annoncé padura détecter
trouvé par contre réfuté c'était très
difficile pour manu ça je suis d'accord
mais ok comprendre que faire fou aux
cinq laisser le roi se cachant en h2 et
fait refouler de après que c'est pas
super ça mais ça n'importe qui sauf à
n'importe qui c'est mais après trouver
pourquoi et rites funèbres comme partir
quand il fait quelque 1 kg de oui oui
c'est pareil oui tu sais que c'est pas
bon même
regagné victoire si on pensait que le
match est complètement tournée pour manu
c'est la boum ace et ça en fait c'est
quand même
fini et le temps joue vraiment parce que
le fait de cette année aussi mal autant
sa
façon ça vaut son pesant d'or mais une
époque au corps qui se trouvent dame 17
mai 2007 pour moi lille a trouvé assez
terrible magnus qui est peut-être en
train de vaciller le champion du monde
fab en sueur il est moins bien on en
croit le joueur russe qui peut faire
offrir du pain gay demain attention et
surtout qu il ya six coups et à une
position chiante mais c'est incroyable
fin peut-être une victoire au noir je
vois ces visionnages sur ces 5 oui mais
c'est pas si grave franck et 4 jusqu'en
b4 et tour c1 mais bah du coup tout
juste ma faim l'
incroyable mais attends faut prendre b4
s'est pas fait encore non ces séries
encore le cavalier qui va partir au real
est parfait mais tu amènes thon rouge en
recettes tu fais cinq élèves quatre
dames b5 important à mon avis tu défends
ton truc mettons m et ours et 7 je sais
pas c'est compliqué c'est hyper chaud ou
encore fabrice en effet dans cette
partie ça a peut-être jean baudron quand
même
il n'y a plus beaucoup de temps on va
laisser la bombe a vu du dessus ok je
dois dire un bon francs mais capt'ain
doit faire face on sature affiche un
matin il ya aussi dû aux cimes court 1
qui peut être intéressant fab parce que
le fou il est pas si mal placé et
contrôler certains cavaliers cloud et
willy réfléchi il est réfléchi fabre
regarde où il a peut-être il a peut-être
parce que si costa interdit des cas